Uh, hello.
Welcome to day three.
Welcome.
I never expected to live this far.
But here we are.
Day three of Minecraft Twitch Rivals!
Let's fucking go!
Good morning, everyone.
Good morning.
Give it up for day three!
Day fucking three!
Oh shit, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I already misbroke the rule.
Okay, so for those who don't know, today, they're enforcing rules more heavily.
So, other than the fact that we're not... they're like, guys, they had like a...
today, this morning, they had like, they're enforcing... they're like, we're gonna be enforcing rules now, more...
more strictly.
And then, so like, other stuff, it's like, understandable.
No metagaming, like, no stream sniping.
You know, stuff like that.
That we don't do.
And then, they're like, no...
no mic spamming.
Like, no...
playing copyright music.
Because remember yesterday, people were obnoxiously playing copyright music yesterday.
So they were like, no copyright music.
Uh, we're not allowed to like, talk to people outside of the in-game voice chat.
Stuff like that.
Um, so, cause like, people were talking, you know, people were interacting with like, with... apparently some people were interacting on like, Discord and stuff.
Like, with Discord audio.
So like, no voice proximity.
Which I was like, oh my god, that's so smart.
But also, oh my god!
Wait, that's cheating!
So...
So they were enforcing that.
But the one rule that stood out to me the most...
No profanity.
So...
So no more profanity for this bird.
So that was like, one of the the five rules.
I don't know, five or six rules that they're trying to enforce.
Now...
There was another one that interested me.
Not as like, isn't like, oh, I'm gonna do it.
But like, one of them was like, uh, no!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, let me read it again.
I thought that rule was so interesting.
Cause I'm like, wait, we're actually not allowed to do that?
Let me find it again.
It was actually, I was like, what the heck?
See, I'm learning.
But one of them...
Oh my gosh, where is it?
Where's the general announcement?
Oh yeah!
Uh, unfair competition, negative behavior, and dishonest acts are strictly forbidden!
So that means, no gaslighting!
Players are expected to maintain a positive attitude towards fellow competitors!
And organizers to ensure a friendly environment!
Okay, it doesn't say no gaslighting, but it says unfair competition and negative behavior and dishonest acts are strictly forbidden.
I assume that means you can't gaslight others!
I assume!
I don't know if that's true or not.
But like, uh, but like, I assume that's what it means.
Because like, what does like, what does like, uh, what does like, dishonest acts mean?
Or like, or like, negative, like, what does that mean?
This is like that one guy that was like, this is the wrong house!
Does that count?
Like, is, remember when like, Agumi and I were running towards the house, and then one of them was like, this, like, is fake comms considered dishonest?
Like, does that count?
I don't know!
But like, that rule is actually pretty frickin' vague.
Okay, I had to uh, that rule was pretty frickin' vague.
So like, I couldn't really tell, uh, what that actually meant.
Um, also, uh, apparently you're allowed, uh, you're allowed to rat out other prop players if you're a prop.
And like, that's messed up.
Like, cause like, that's so, like, why, like, who would wanna be a prop at that point?
Like, just eliminate a fellow prop player!
Yeah!
You're allowed to, like, shout, like, rat other prop members out!
Okay, so the fourth game, the fourth, okay, wait, one, two, okay, sorry, the fifth game.
The fifth game is called, like, uh, Duck Duck Curse or some shit.
I mean, some frick.
I'm trying.
Okay.
I'm trying really hard.
I'm not a Minecraft player, so that's built in.
Man, I'm an FPS gamer.
We've said, like, I've heard and said, like, so much profanity, and I've heard so much worse.
Anyway.
Anyway, so basically, it's like, uh, RNG, so we have to run around and find, like, cursed dolls, and then we have to, like, uh, but the thing is, the cursed doll can either be safe or a curse.
So it's, like, RNG.
Um, so you don't know if you're gonna get the curse or the safe doll.
And then when you find the cursed doll, you have to run away, because, like, I assume they look like this, I assume, because these look like cursed dolls.
So, like, you have to, like, run away, and if you get caught, you get eliminated.
Oh my gosh, if I get eliminated on the first game, oh my gosh.
Freedom.
I mean, it would be fun if day four...
Anyway, freedom is so close.
Anyway, day, uh, okay, game game five game five is ten people will be eliminated, but game six, thirty people will be eliminated.
Right now, players are arguing with the organizers on whether or not you should be allowed to rat out other prop prop players, because one of them was, like, one of, one of, I saw people using the rules against the admins, and was, like, ratting other prop members is negative behavior.
So vague!
Like, that's what I'm saying!
Those rules are so goddamn vague!
Like, so, like, I see like, people in the server, the discord chat, was like, that is negative behavior because it's griefing other players!
So, so, um...
So, it's, like, dishonest!
It ruins competitive integrity!
So, like, the admins and, like, the players are, like, arguing right now about it, and that's why we're not starting it.
I think, I think, there's 94 players?
Oh, that means, like, all of them are just admins.
Like, how is there 94 players?
There should be only 80 players.
How is there, like, so many admins?
Not the competitive integrity.
That's why we're not starting it, because people are, like, arguing right now about the rules for the second game.
I mean, that's what I'm saying!
It's so vague!
Like, what counts as what counts as competitive and, like, what counts as negative?
Negative behavior!
It's so goddamn vague!
Oh, they're making changes to the launcher?
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, I don't know.
Yeah, and apparently, okay, one other funny thing is that people were complaining about the copyright music that was being played yesterday.
Like, whoever that little hecker was that...
that...
Because, like, apparently people, like, uploaded their bots and got copyright striked.
Yeah!
Like, whoever that was, I don't know if they're still in this lobby, but people were complaining because they're, like, we got a copyright strike because someone got, like, um...
Someone, you know, people were playing copyright music.
So people were like, bro, my bot got a strike!
Like, bro, I got a claim!
I can't monetize it!
So yeah, I thought that was...
Well, to me, it was funny.
But, like, obviously, that sucks, man.
Like, that sucks, bro.
But, like, to me, that was pretty funny.
Alright.
Alright, I guess...
I guess we should...
I guess we cannot take meds for a little bit.
Alright.
Where is everybody?
There should be, like, 90 players.
Where is Gumi?
I need her to clutch it for me.
I need her to...
I need her to, like, move on to day 4 for me and suffer.
I was just, like, a colleague before.
Alright, where is me?
A, B, C...
Wait, where is D?
Oh, my God.
All the Ds are almost dead.
Except for me!
Yay!
It's not metagaming because it's happening in-game.
Which is not allowed to metagame outside, like, outside of the game.
Uh...
Whoa!
Guys!
Oh, my God, do you see that?
Guys, it's already getting spicy in the server.
People are already playing music in the lobby.
Can we please stop that?
Oh, no!
It's already getting spicy!
Oh, my God!
They have to write it in Spanish too because they don't know!
They don't know!
It was just a language barrier.
To be fair, the complaints of it was mostly in English, so I don't know if the Spanish players knew that that was not allowed.
Oh, my God.
You got called out in two languages.
Oh, my God, in front of everybody!
Oh, my God!
In front of everyone!
Holy shit!
Oh, shoot!
Holy shoot!
Oh, my God!
Gumi's in the kitchen.
Gumi's gonna carry me, right?
She's gonna...
She's gonna carry me, right?
Liars!
There's no Gumi in here.
There is a TV.
She's in the dining hall?
That's not a kitchen!
Guys, you guys need to know the difference between a kitchen and a dining hall.
What?
Actually?
Oh, my gosh!
What is the admin calling out about now?
Oh!
Oh, my God!
The callouts are real!
I told you guys.
They're enforcing the rules like legit now.
Gumi!
We're live!
Get in the backpack!
Get in!
Yay!
I told you guys, but your skin...
You put it on wrong.
I know.
I can't be bothered.
I know since day one.
I can't be bothered!
Tucker, Pickle...
I don't know if I...
As long as the front works, that's all that matters.
Hello, Shane.
Yeah, okie-dokie.
That was a funny joke.
Okie-dokie.
What the?
Duh.
Hi, guys.
Gumi, did you see the hard enforcement of rules today?
I did!
Did you see that?
No swearing!
Hello?
You found one, Sam?
What's up, Gumiho?
Today will probably be the most RNG day, I think.
Gummy!
Well, ouch.
Well, also, I wonder...
I wonder if it's going to be like...
So tired already.
You guys find any over here, Oli?
The thing is, I don't know if like...
If you get eliminated...
As a hider...
Like, as a prop hider...
Like, how do the hunters get eliminated then?
Like, I don't understand.
Why would the prop players want to call each other?
Why would the prop players...
Call out other prop players?
Because how would the hunters die?
Like, I feel like that's just...
That's just...
That's just dumb!
Gummy, do you understand the...
Prop hunt thing?
On how it's getting...
I thought prop hunt would be like a team game.
But do you see people arguing about whether or not you can call...
Like, throw other prop players under the bus?
To get eliminated?
I did see that.
Yeah, so I'm confused.
I thought the prop hunt was a team-based game.
No, I think it's a one-for-all.
But then how would the hunters get eliminated?
I guess like...
If they don't hunt enough?
If they don't get at least one person or something?
Yeah, but then like, prop players can get eliminated by like...
You know, getting caught.
So like, how would...
That's so... That's so confusing.
So like, it's better...
It's just better to be a hunter...
Than a prop player.
Yeah...
And Frost!
I have 28!
Oh, for an important...
Oh, important announcement.
Server restarting?
Oh, they're restarting the server.
I thought...
Aww, I wish it was a team game.
Any music of any kind is not allowed in voice chat.
Nooooo!
Why are you guys...
Complaining about...
Minecraft, please.
I'm just like...
Why does it matter?
Why?
I'm so...
I'm so confused!
Why would it matter if you can't play...
If you...
If you want to play music...
In voice chat...
Just play music in your own stream.
You have to realize that.
That doesn't make sense to me.
I'm sorry.
I'm not... I don't understand.
Guys, I actually...
I don't understand.
Okay.
Alright.
Voice chat will be completely disabled by the server in...
Oh, in prop hunt.
Oh!
Hello?
Hey!
So...
Yeah?
I found out...
Okay, so they're turning up voice chat...
For the prop hunt thing, so we don't grief each other.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure...
It's like...
Hunters have to at least get one.
I'm pretty sure it's going to be a really big house.
So like...
It makes it even...
That hunters only have to get one and props have to survive.
I...
I'm just making...
That's why I'm like...
The transform run is just so confusing.
I'm just...
But I also don't like that we have to do tasks.
Yeah, you have to do tasks as a prop.
So it feels like it's better to be a hunter than a prop.
Because it's easier to grab...
Like hunt props.
Than it is to like...
Be a prop.
And then you have to like...
Make sure you don't get caught while doing tasks.
Because I feel like props will get eliminated so fast.
Because of it.
Yeah, I agree.
Yeah.
That's why I was like so confused.
It would have been better if it was just a team game.
And then like all the props...
Or like if the hunters win and get everybody.
All the props...
Would win on one side.
Because then it's more RNG.
And like people can actually work together.
Yeah.
It's kind of like...
You're trying to think of like prop hunt rules.
Yeah.
Because I feel like it's hard to limit...
Because it's just better to be RNG'd as a hunter.
Than it is to be RNG'd as a prop.
Because like...
What if you just don't do anything?
What if you just do one task?
And then like...
Or like what if all the prop players...
Successfully do all the tasks?
And not like...
It's just confusing.
Are you in the lobby now?
I'm launching.
Yeah, yeah.
Because you see the new...
They're like nobody is allowed to use third priority.
I was like...
People were using Discord?
Dude, I thought that shit wasn't allowed.
Like from day one.
Yeah.
And then I'm like...
Did they get disqualified?
Or are they still in the game?
I'm like...
That's pretty unfair.
They're using Discord groups.
I have to deal with 100 people...
Mic spamming my lobby.
And they get to be in a Discord group?
Yeah, what's it called?
I found out that in-game...
I forgot that in-game voice...
Yeah, it has a group chat.
They disabled it.
Yeah, I asked a question about it and they're like...
No!
Not allowed.
Yeah, so for chat, for those who don't know...
This is actually not allowed.
The group voice chat.
Even though it's in the game.
It's not allowed.
They want everybody to have...
To use voice proximity.
Alright, I'm launching now.
Alright, I'll see you in game.
Bye-bye.
Guys, I'm pretty sure...
Guys...
If we make it to the second game...
If I get propped...
It's over.
It's so over.
What we discovered.
Guys, they actually have to...
Disable the voice chat.
So it's emotes mode only.
In the transform...
In the prop hut.
No, we have to do tasks.
Dude, if we're propped...
We have to do tasks.
So we can't stay at propped forever.
We have to move around...
And do stuff.
And that's what I'm saying!
If we get propped...
The RNG is so bad.
Because the hunter...
We have to camp the...
I guess if they don't know the task...
They can't camp it.
But it feels like it's easier...
To be a hunter.
Yeah.
The hunter advantage.
It's so...
Oh my god.
It's so big.
30 people will be eliminated.
Transport in the prop hut 2.
Because I'm like thinking...
I honestly thought it was supposed to be...
A team game.
That's like legit.
That's what I thought.
I was like oh my gosh.
It's like a team game.
Because like whoever...
Whichever side wins...
They can move on.
But no.
It's not a team game.
It's a one for all.
Every...
Every hunter and prop for themselves.
Chat.
Alright.
Let's see.
They're completely disabling voice chat.
So other props...
Other props can't throw...
Throw each other out.
To get eliminated fast.
That just makes me wonder.
I guess like props...
That have the least completed task...
Get eliminated.
But then like...
What if there's like...
We should gatekeep Ambrose.
Okay.
How many eggs do you guys have?
I'm just like thinking like...
I'm just thinking like...
What if we have...
Like what if we...
Have more...
More members...
Like I guess we'll have to do tiebreakers.
Because what if like...
There's hunters that got like zero kills.
And there's props that done zero tasks.
But like...
Zero tasks.
But there's like more...
How do you eliminate all of them?
All the guardians look the same in my eyes.
Yeah I brought us to the wrong side.
Where are we going?
Is there a third one?
This is just like...
Where are we going?
Gumi doesn't have any of the eggs.
Gumi has zero bro.
Why am I bald?
Average day.
Registered in the state of YouTube.
Oh!
Wait I don't care.
About easter eggs.
Oh my gosh.
I actually don't care about the easter eggs.
So Gumi is a third one?
Like besides the parkour one and the other one?
Like a hidden one?
What are we doing?
Are we still finding easter eggs?
Cause like there's no...
There's no...
That's a lie.
What?
I remember you lied before.
I'm gonna stand on it.
Yeah who needs eggs?
Wait is there another...
There's another ad.
An announcement?
Oh my god look at the crowd.
For the easter eggs.
It's like when you dangle keys in front of a baby.
But you dangle...
Oh my god there is one here!
How many do you have?
28.
Oh okay.
It's like dangling keys in front of a child.
Or dangling easter eggs.
In front of like the Minecraft players.
So like...
To like pad the time.
Oh my god.
Where's your hat?
That's what I'm saying.
Where'd my hair go?
Oh my god.
It looks like you shaved the top of your head.
Hold my hand.
What happened to your skin?
I don't know.
What did you do?
I don't feel so good.
Does it look right?
It doesn't look right.
It doesn't look right at all.
Where did she go?
Oh my god she died!
Oh my god!
She disappeared!
One less player.
One less player to worry about.
I'm joking guys!
I'm joking!
Chad!
She carried me all the way to game day 3.
There goes your kegs.
Exactly!
Guys!
I'm joking.
I need her to carry me.
Wait.
No.
She's gone.
There's a high chance I'll get eliminated.
On the first game.
And if I get eliminated on the first game...
I don't have to do day 4.
I don't need to do day 4.
One last game.
I don't know.
I can just... I can just not... not stream tomorrow.
No, Doki, you gotta try.
Doki.
Doki is losing it.
All I'm saying, guys, with Gumi eliminated, there is a high chance that I too will be eliminated.
Snap out of it.
I don't have to stay awake and I'm holding everybody hostage, even my own.
I'm holding myself hostage.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's the new... there's a new announcement.
What is it?
Alright.
Alright, what is the new... guys, seriously, stop playing music over a mic!
Are people still doing this?
Bro.
Oh my god.
People are admin mad.
Admin's actually mad.
They're like, alright, we're actually gonna remove people now.
You keep playing music.
Oh my god, guys.
I'm gonna start snitching.
Oh my god, it's time.
It's time.
It's time to start my Doki arc and start snitching.
Quick, play music and be free.
No, no.
If I can, like, catch people.
If I can catch people playing music, one less person to worry about.
No negativity, remember?
It's not negativity.
I'm looking at the competitive integrity.
Of this game.
Oh my god, you're right.
If I play...
That's actually messed up.
That's like a brilliant plan.
Like, oh my god, a villain came up with this perfect plan.
That's when you know I'm not a villain.
Because the fact that... and like, I'm not an actual villain.
Because even I wouldn't have come up with that.
But someone in my chat was like, quick, play music over a group of people and call somebody out.
That's so evil.
That's actually so god damn evil.
Oh my god.
You, sir, are a very evil person.
That's so...
Guys, the Among Us part of this game ended, chat.
Oh my god, we're 30...
We're 33 minutes late.
Because the server is messed up at the moment.
Oh, okay.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, wait, what was the info?
What was the info?
Yeah.
Okay, they were saying that the doll, every level, would speed up.
Oh.
Okay, so the bad doll is gonna get faster and faster.
Ooh, okay.
Interesting.
They have someone working for them.
Yeah, they have someone on the inside.
Yeah, they got a guy on the inside.
That's crazy.
Ooh.
Guys, we got insider info.
I'm gonna snitch them out for it.
Hey.
You heard the secrets too?
Yeah.
We're being spied on, James.
The TV up there?
No, there is a TV up there, though, if you need to get down.
Oh, I got that one.
I got three secret guys.
I didn't know that.
Well, you're gonna do uninstall the info from my brain?
Oh, thank God.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna snitch them.
I'm gonna snitch them out to the admins.
One of your admin gave the other...
One of your...
One of your admins gave the other player insight.
Insider info.
So, she was metagaming.
She was metagaming.
Rule number 33.
I don't know where anymore are.
Oh, my God.
Goomy, goomy, goomy.
I heard insider info from somebody that's apparently friends with the admin.
They were telling one player that, like, the doll...
It's gonna get faster and faster each round.
The evil doll.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, God.
Is this one hide-and-seek?
Or is it hide-and-seek tag or something?
It's like hide-and-seek tag.
It seems like it's almost like musical chairs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Musical chairs with hide-and-seek.
Yeah.
So, like, if you are unlucky and you get a bad doll, you have to start hiding.
You know, I find it funny, Ant, how we were saying we want to search everywhere but the black corner.
And that's exactly where it was.
Yeah.
I feel like my frames are dropping.
Does it really matter, though?
The frames are...
I was doing 30 before and now I'm at 100.
You were running 30.
Oh, yeah.
I'm at 100, too.
Yesterday, I was running 30 in the lobby.
There's a lot more people yesterday, too.
They did also...
I'm back.
They did turn down the default run distance, as well.
All right.
Oh.
I turned it back up, though, because I just wasn't rendering, like, the whole, like, lobby.
Yeah.
I turned down the render distance just because I didn't need that much.
It was, like, at 20.
I might turn it back down, to be honest.
I'm at, like, 8.
I'm at, like...
People are still complaining about the music.
I don't think it matters if the frames are low.
Yeah.
But, like, we're not, like, talking during the game.
We're just talking while we wait for the event to start.
I know.
But, like...
Yeah.
I'm at around, like, 3,000 renders right now.
I did the same thing.
I was, like...
I feel like they're talking about us, but...
That might work.
We're, like, the only ones on.
We're all on call.
So, I don't know.
So, how's the rest week?
All right, guys.
Well, I've been in the server with 100-plus people for, like, three days straight.
Oh, my God.
Guys, look.
A knight right there.
My social battery is not okay at the moment.
I vanished into a wall.
It's not okay.
Oh.
You silly Billy.
Sounds like the opposite of resting.
Oh, my God.
10 seconds.
10 seconds, guys.
Oh, my God.
I cannot wait.
I cannot wait to be the first 10 out.
I can't wait, guys.
What the...
What the fuck is this?
Whoa.
Stop it!
You sound... Doki, please, at least, like, pretend.
Guys, help me out.
Guys...
Oh, but don't eliminate it, guys.
Oh, wait.
Hey!
Alright, all on red!
All on red!
Yeah!
Go bring my meds!
I need to take my meds soon!
Alright, I should take my meds.
Oh my god, the voices, they're getting louder!
They're getting...
The one with the most people, like...
I wonder, are they gonna TP us?
Based off of what color we're standing on?
Maybe let's stand up...
Well, maybe later we'll go on red, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, sure.
Oh, I have an idea.
If we both...
If we both pick the same doll, the doll will only kill one of us.
That sounds like the most...
Worst idea you've ever come up with.
But, like, that's why it's a 50-50.
No, it sounds like you're a dumb...
What?
You can't swear profanity!
I didn't swear!
What were you saying?
Just dumb!
You're just dumb!
I feel like there was a second word there!
Dumb bear!
All I'm saying is that this doll will only pick one of us.
Look around!
Do you think you're gonna hide?
Stop talking to me!
I think it's a good plan.
I don't understand.
You're the same person who doesn't know how to read.
Yeah, but that doesn't require reading.
It's just probability.
It's math.
We're next to the...
Wait, the Spanish players know what they're doing.
Oh.
Oh my god!
It's like roulette!
Any of you remain with a chance to escape the house of nightmares.
But it won't be easy.
And for this next challenge...
Wait, what?
You'll have some company.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's so scary.
This is literally RNG.
Oh, I hate this.
My stress is already going up.
Each of these dolls are either a safe doll or a cursed one.
I hate this.
You will each choose a doll by standing...
I'm already anxious.
Once the time runs out...
Your choice will be locked.
The doll chosen by the most players will become the group's selection.
And the nature of your doll will be revealed.
There are only five dolls of this type left?
You'll be safe until your next selection.
Bro, what?
If the group chooses a cursed doll, you'll face dire consequences as the evil spirits of that doll will be out to get you.
Wait, then how do you live?
You just run around the circle?
The spirits will spawn in the form of multiple dolls who will chase you for five minutes Bro, what the heck?
when only one player is eliminated.
Each doll has different abilities.
That's so scary!
Some have the ability to multiply That's gonna be me.
And others will hurl fireballs.
What?
When being chased, you can hide in places like toy boxes, arcade machines, or clothing drawers by clicking on them.
Can they like...
Can they like open the place?
Hiding spots only protect you for a few seconds.
Wait, that's dumb!
And each hiding spot will only be used once before disappearing for the remainder of the rounds.
So choose wisely when and where you hide.
Guys, I'm already stressed out listening to this.
The dolls will be held too fast to outrun.
Your only option for safety will be the remaining hiding spots.
After each elimination a new round will start.
Guys...
Let's gotcha!
Quenching the conjurer's blood thirst.
I'm gonna use all of them so no one can hide.
That's so true.
That's actually so scary.
Oh my god.
What?
I think it's really really quiet.
I don't know which one of them.
It's only if you choose the doll that's...
I'm listening to other people's I'm listening to other people's I'm listening to other people's I'm listening to other people's I'm listening to other people's right now.
It's...
Yeah,
the fridge is gonna save us!
The fridge is gonna save us!
So we're gonna pick the same square together?
Oh yeah.
Okay, remember, use the hiding spots later.
Oh, okay.
But what if, like...
But if we use up all the hiding spaces then nobody can get it.
Yeah, but I mean you also can't get it, idiot.
Yeah, but the probability-wise...
Yeah, I don't think it matters where you stand.
I feel like...
I don't know.
The same odds on each one, but whichever one gets selected, you're competing against everyone.
Can we all agree not to use the hiding cluster later in the game?
Let's use the hiding cluster.
Is everybody in the room chased or just the people on the thing?
Why would it be...
No, I shouldn't stick with the pros because the pros are faster runners.
I'm trying to play DBD and just break their ankles, man.
All I'm saying, guys, that doesn't...
Guys, if I always stick with the pros, if we get RNG into a core stall, all of them are better players than me.
And they would kill me first.
They're faster runners.
Oh, wow.
Holy crap.
Oh, my God.
I don't know.
Yeah, I'm...
That's why I'm scared.
Do you want to be the big one?
So, just spread it out.
What happens if I'm not surviving?
My competitor desk is messing me up, guys.
Yeah, I think everybody goes there.
Oh, okay.
It's yours.
Those little voices.
Those little voices are so strong.
I can't.
I...
I survived.
I'm surprised I survived as long as I could.
I'm surprised I survived this long.
It was just...
It was a lie.
All right.
If I stick with...
I think I'm going to stick with the crowd then.
The more people...
I guess, like, the more people there are in that space...
Um...
The...
Uh...
Oh...
Who is everybody voting for?
If there's a huge amount of people together...
Then, like, probability-wise...
Maybe?
I'm a little stressed.
Wait...
Ah...
We all suffer the same fate to get there.
Oh, God.
I'm actually anxious.
I don't know why.
I don't know why I'm so anxious.
No!
There's only one dog?
That's messed up.
That's actually messed up.
That's so messed up, guys.
That's so messed up!
How did I... Oh my...
Oh, Chris.
It's me.
It always happens.
To Doki!
The Doki experience.
Right here.
The Doki experience right now.
This is the Doki experience.
Oh, wait.
Everybody's running.
Why is everybody running right now?
Five minutes of this.
FIVE MINUTES OF THIS!
If I stand in the middle...
Oh, no.
A lot of people are running away.
So that makes me really nervous.
Like, why are people running away?
I wanna stay near the crowd.
Audio for you.
It's impossible.
Go!
Oh, what?
What happened?
Run!
Why are you running?
Because it's coming.
You can't even see it!
It's coming!
Into!
I didn't know if you were just getting your steps in.
Oh, my God.
Yay, free intel!
The herd mentality!
I love following the herd!
I've been doing the whole lobby here!
Follow the herd!
What does it mean if you're even safe?
What does Sigma?
Follow the herd.
Mob strong.
What does Sigma?
I like crowds.
I don't mind.
Mob.
That's where I want to be, Derek.
Guys, stop laughing at me.
Two minutes, two minutes for you.
Just hold, hold, hold.
Holy, I'm normal.
I'm raving.
Nah, I'm just lying.
Serpia, you're normal.
Strong.
Together.
No!
Nah, that was Aura, bro.
Bro, that was Aura.
Plus 1000 Aura.
Strong.
Is he coming?
Kill someone, bro.
Just kill someone.
This doll got one tapped, man.
Is he coming?
I'm worried at the end it's going to go like hyperspeed and we're all going to get bopped.
All 40 of us in here are going to be the ones to get out.
If no one dies, there's going to be 10 rounds until someone dies.
Like, 15 minutes.
Yeah, we all win.
They have to split the money.
They give us each $70,000.
Can we vote someone to be like $70,000?
Not it.
This is my goddamn life!
Okay, fine.
We'll sacrifice Andre.
This has to be the lock into me!
What's his color?
Yo, I'll sacrifice for 40 Gs.
Wait, I have a question.
I have a question for Scott.
He didn't help me out.
I'll sacrifice one per person.
Sorry.
I'm losing it.
I'm actually losing it.
So...
Of course the gray person's the weakest.
I'm stuck in Purgatory!
This is frickin' Purgatory!
I don't know.
There's no man once per round.
If you're safe, is that actually a thing?
Is it even safe?
Dude, I'm nervous.
I don't know.
I don't know where it is.
Some people are here, though.
Can we do a head count, guys?
It has to be like one person and then we're free!
That's what it really is!
50 seconds.
Just wait.
Marco!
Polo!
Guys, always go to the same color.
It's coming!
He's coming!
Polo!
It's coming!
He's behind us!
Polo!
Run into it!
Let's run into it!
Oh my God!
It hit me!
Woah!
I saw someone die here!
I got hit!
What?
They didn't get one?
How do I come back to the room?
I got hit.
I got hit twice by it.
Oh my god.
My health restored.
That was so stressful.
Where is the entrance?
TPS, TPS, TPS.
Oh, it's here.
Oh.
Oh, we're back.
What?
Do we go all on the same line?
Purple.
Blue, blue, blue, blue.
I knew it, I knew it.
It's fine.
I knew it.
It's okay.
There's a crowd.
That's all sweet.
It's going to be me, right?
It's going to be me.
I'm okay!
Nice.
Wait, all of us have chosen the same?
Wait, what?
Oh no, not yet.
Where did we choose this?
No, it's going to be good.
It's going to be good.
Not too bad.
I mean, at least there's no RNG on what we choose.
Okay.
There's a huge crowd here.
I'm confused.
I'm...
What?
No!
That's me, right?
Okay, bye-bye.
That's me, that's me!
We should stop listening to the loud guys.
He's coming, he's coming!
This thing is fast.
Is that all of us?
Wait, is it like majority?
I'm so confused.
It's for everybody!
Is it just one?
I'm dead, I'm dead!
I hear him, I hear him!
I'd rather stay with the group.
We got this.
Oh, there's a group there.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Coming, coming, coming!
He's coming, coming, coming!
This doll is going to have a different ability than the last one.
He's coming?
He's coming or not?
This doll has kill aura.
Is she coming?
Don't attract her, don't attract her!
So you might not be able to outrun it very well.
I'm sure we can still outrun it eventually.
Oh my god!
He's coming, he's coming, he's coming!
Why are you guys yelling?
I got you.
Oh!
He got somebody!
Oh my god!
Another round!
At least we won't have to be here for 50 minutes.
It's so tight!
We played!
Oh my god!
That's probably the worst part of all of this.
The save dolls are just pointless.
This is so stressful.
Yeah.
Oh man.
Anyone but the weak will get gone.
Dude, I saw this!
You do not go back to the middle!
I was dictating!
I was getting scared!
I was alone!
We got it!
AAAAHHH!!
Aghhh!
We're back.
Alright.
Let's fucking go!
Yes we are ready!
Let's fucking go.
Let's go!
I dont know which side to go.
Let's keep going!
I can't move.
Watch that angle to the left, we need someone to watch that angle over here.
I don't like this...
Just keep swimming!
I don't like that.
Are you running?
No, no, no, we're fine.
It's a terrible spot!
It's actually not terrible.
No, it's the best as fuck!
Guys, I'm scared, I don't want to die.
Run the dog!
RUN THE DOG!
They're trolling, they're trolling, it's a lie.
They're trolling, dude.
I got the cry of help, though.
The cry of help.
I'm serious!
How many dogs are there?
Multiple, multiple.
There were two before, there were two before.
Oh my god.
Hold the corner, hold the corner!
The cry of help there was incredible.
Panic!
Fear!
What is going on?
Absolute fear and mayhem.
That's what...
That's what's going on.
Oh my god.
This is like the Stanford Prison Experiment.
I swear, son!
Researchers are gonna see this.
They're gonna study this!
I'm going through this game.
Oh no.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Go right, go right, go right!
I peaced away from the group.
Guys.
I'm so scared.
No.
Other way, other way.
Run, other way, other way!
Oh my god, Ollie!
Oh my god, there's multiple cuts!
Ollie, Ollie!
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
There's multiple cuts.
We got eliminated.
Ollie got shanked.
Awesome!
You're just a bad luck!
Good luck!
Trust me!
Here we go again.
It doesn't matter.
It's majority.
It's always majority.
That's the thing.
It doesn't matter.
It's literally majority picks.
Everybody still has to run.
So it doesn't matter if you pick a safe doll.
If the majority picks a bad doll, it's over.
No matter what, somebody has to die.
8 more to go.
I'm fine.
There's nothing here.
There's like 8 more dolls to go.
They're coming.
Anyone on the right?
We don't want to run into anything too.
Okay.
Trust me.
I hope it means like the dolls are fast.
They kill people faster.
Because each round is faster.
I'm so scared.
Oh, we're so good.
They want that info.
I don't know.
Hi.
Apparently the suits are not very safe.
They're running on the left.
They'll camp you.
They'll camp you?
Then there's no point in having hiding spots.
Okay, you know what?
Go!
Okay, run, run, run.
We'll be right back.
They're beaches.
Okay, okay, okay.
My heart.
My poor heart.
Oh, boy.
We're chill, I think.
It's kind of clear.
But I don't know where it went.
Guys, were we locked in there?
We're tilling, guys.
It looks like we're okay.
Play the corner.
One more.
How many hearts?
It does half a heart.
You can get hit four times.
Take off for the team.
Thank you for the 10,000 biddies!
Thank you for following my therapy.
Sam?
Are you running?
Are you okay?
There's two dolls that direction, but they turned left.
There's two dolls that direction.
I think we're good over here right now.
Are they faster than you running?
Definitely faster.
Don't leave the group.
The dolls will find you.
I left the group and I got fucking tapped.
Don't leave the group.
Together always.
You don't regen.
No, you don't regen.
Somebody sacrificed Doki.
Wait, why me?
I didn't do anything.
I'm just a baby.
Doki is cool.
Music is getting very loud.
I don't have any music.
Doki alone.
Is that why there's music?
Is anybody being hunted?
No.
Hi Sean.
Negative behavior.
We'll see you.
No pee-pee.
Pee-pee your pants.
Pee-pee my pants.
Shut up.
Go, go, go.
Nothing to be afraid of.
We're chilling.
No, we're not chilling.
I do nap.
I do not chill.
I do not chill anymore.
Okay.
Yes, we're not chill.
Oh my God.
Do not chill.
I messed up the stairs.
I'm not in the group.
I'm gonna do the kanga.
Everybody kanga.
My God.
The mic is bad.
Guys, how do we get intel on everybody's yank.
Oh God, this is not intel.
This is just a school trip that you can't get off of.
You can't get out.
This is worse.
It's like a mandatory school trip.
I sure hope the next one is a safe doll.
I sure hope it's a safe doll.
Karma!
He actually got Karma!
Yeah, he got it!
I'm gonna throw up.
I hate this.
Steve actually got Karma.
That's so funny.
I hate this!
This is worse.
This is it.
I'm after Abe.
Are you goddamn- It doesn't matter anyway, guys.
No, what am I saying?
It doesn't matter.
It's better.
It's majority.
I feel like when people pick safe dolls, they should be safe.
I feel like if you pick safe dolls, you should automatically be safe.
Barpo, Barpo, you went alone last time.
We should not be forced to do this.
We should not be forced.
Why even vote?
I don't know why.
Yeah, but if you have a safe doll, you shouldn't be forced to do this again.
I feel like he might be revived.
Is he coming?
Oh my god, the illusion choice.
This is the illusion choice.
My heart can't take this.
You vote, we all lose.
It's a guy that wants to be my wife.
No!
Six more to go.
What is this?
This guy forgot, lost his male wife.
It doesn't matter where we're... they randomly put us... they randomly group us out.
It doesn't matter where we're...
Cheap, he died in front of me in my arms.
It doesn't matter where, like, you get grouped up into.
It's, like, random.
Wait, no, no, Cheap, it actually was invisible.
No, it was invisible, Cheap, I swear.
It was actually not there and then spawned in.
Don't do black, don't do black, don't do black, don't do black.
Listen, the trick is...
Alright, I'll be up next to this door.
But I, I, I actually got caught on something and the doll was face to face with me and walked by me instead, so...
I'm ready, Banzai.
Yup, yup, yup.
So, like, able to damage you.
Oh, no!
It doesn't matter.
I'm not even on that, but we all get caught.
This one is, this one is very hard, you guys.
No, it doesn't exist.
Alright, alright, alright.
We know the route, we know the route, guys.
We know...
We know the route, we know the route, we know the route.
We know the route, guys, we know the route.
We know the route...
To the corner, to the corner.
We know the route.
Hold up, hold up.
I'm in the middle.
Because I don't contribute.
No, no, no.
We know Dundrills.
I'm a leech.
I'm just here to leech.
I'm good, I'm good.
I'm safe, no worries.
Oh my god.
Dukie rat tactics.
Of course.
They're running, they're running, they're running.
They're running away from the hot pack in a minute.
Oh my god.
They're running away.
I'm running for nothing, bro.
I'm running for nothing.
Stop it, stop it, stop it, stop it.
Stop it, stop it, guys.
Intersection, intersection.
Nah, fuck intersection.
Stop it, stop it, stop it.
Hold the corner.
Corner, corner, corner.
It's such a grief, bro.
Did you guys see anything?
Yeah, we got shot at.
Why didn't we see anything?
I was like, we're gonna go for a little- Oh, sorry.
The little kid behind the bar.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Where's my mom?
The kid at the supermarket?
I don't know.
You guys, let me- The kid at the supermarket.
The kid at the supermarket, where's my mom?
Sam?
Sam's balls are on the ground dude, that's crazy.
Sam!
Bro I thought game day 2 was bad.
I don't know, this is worse.
This is actually much worse than day 2.
I think everybody can kill the doll.
Sam just said info, we're good.
This is worse.
And I have to listen to the voices.
I need an adult.
I need an adult guys.
The voices.
I'm just worried about the situation.
We're waiting here, one comes, we run the other way and get totally pinched.
They're running, they're running.
Watch out for being pinched, watch in front of you.
Following Sam, following Sam.
Everyone go the same way.
Don't split, don't split, don't split.
Don't split guys, don't split, don't split.
Sam, Sam, Sam.
Did you guys hear that?
There's so many people.
Sam, Sam, Sam.
Sam, please save us.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Sam, no, no, this is a terrible corner.
They can sneak up behind us.
I like it.
Let's go to the center, go to the center.
Or, or, or, or...
Don't let me go.
Nice corner!
I am 4.3!
Pornen!
I can't believe it!
TwitchSames is back!
Oh, there's one!
Save,
save, save, save, save, guys.
Still run, still run, still run.
Still run, still run.
I sold a player.
We're good, we're good, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Behind, behind, behind, behind, behind!
Ahh, trolled.
Troll, troll, trolled.
Lime, lime, lime, lime, lime, lime.
Both lime, both lime, both lime.
Both lime, lime!
Give it a kiss, give it a kiss.
Don't leave him on top of us.
Kendo, shut up, Kendo, why are you so angry?
Listen to me, listen to me.
No, it's black, it's black now.
I'm so...
I'm so sorry.
Lying, lying, lying.
Green, green, green, green, green, green.
Green is life, green is life.
Green and they're suffering.
Green, green, what's your problem?
Green, what's your problem?
Oh god, I swear.
What does green do?
What's green's power?
You're pro-law, you're suffering.
Green power, green power.
Yeah, this doll has a different melody.
Are you having fun?
These dolls are faster, these dolls are faster, these dolls are faster.
I don't know.
Yay.
Was that good?
I don't know what that even means for us.
Red, we're safe!
What's the matter?
There's no point.
Red, red, red, red, red.
It's a scam.
We're not actually safe.
Blood will be shed on this red pick.
What's the point?
We have to kill it.
Ten people have to die anyways, right?
It's just a game.
Oh, no!
The delusion of choice!
We're just making this round longer!
Stay with the green.
Yeah, regenerate.
Oh, please!
We already had three dolls left.
Six more.
Okay, we obviously know what a good doll looks like.
Light blue, light blue, light blue.
Aqua, Aqua, light blue.
This is bad, this is bad, this is bad, this is bad.
Oh, this man is gonna chase us.
The longer I'm in your support, the sadder he tries.
Oh, this is supposed to be the less stressful one, too!
Oh, yeah, yeah, the colors are going for it.
Oh, yeah.
This is supposed to be the less stressful one.
Safe goals are completely pointless.
Yeah, I'm scared, I'm scared.
What's the point of the...
Yeah, what's the point of the safe one?
Good question!
What is the point of the safe doll?!
Very good question!
Nobody knows.
Nobody knows what's the point of the safe doll.
Yeah, same as always.
I don't know.
Stay in the intersection.
Did you see the lights?
Oh yeah, go, yeah, go, yeah.
Oh, they didn't shoot you?
Stay here, stay here.
Guard this.
We've been chilling here.
We've been chilling.
We've been chilling, we've been chilling.
I like how the Strat is just following the Spanish players.
They know what they're doing.
They know exactly what they're doing.
Oh my god.
$70,000 for Latin America?
That's a lot of money converted for them.
How many are there?
That's when you know they really want to win, guys.
Not gonna lie.
If Latin America...
$70,000?
It's like you're sick.
There's definitely two of these ones.
These guys are running here.
They're running right there.
They're running?
They're running.
Are you laughing?
Can you talk to my left side?
No no no no.
It's just 100 toward me.
Wow wow!
For me, too.
Cause there's a hundred K F tip in here.
Damn this is too many Chromecube messages.
They're running for heaven.
Hey you're reacts a lot...
I'm literally shooting fireballs at people.
I
was 1HP!
I was 1HP!
I would've been out!
Are you like this so you see it from all the noise?
Goomy is so done.
Honestly, say it.
It's magenta!
I was doing it!
Five more.
Five more!
I'll be okay if I get eliminated here.
I actually can.
I can.
I'm so tired.
I'm so goddamn tired.
Oh my god, these are fast.
These are fast.
I'm so tired.
Anyone follow?
Anyone follow us?
Yeah, 1, 1, 1, 1.
Yes, yes, 1, 1, yes, yes, 1, 1, 1.
It's not.
That was fast!
That was so fast!
Oh my god.
They're a lot faster now.
They're a lot faster.
Well, now only the superior red man is left.
We're in the competition.
It's really fast.
Frankie, if you get locked on, you're dead.
You're dead.
Guys, guys.
If he's gonna hit you, just hit the spots.
The hidden spots.
If he's gonna hit you, just thug it out.
Just ignore him.
Thug it out.
Hit the thug shake.
Thug shake.
Ignore him.
Just right click this.
Yeah.
My spot keeps being like this.
I'm gonna take you.
Orange.
This is the social experiment.
This is the Stanford Prison Experiment.
I refuse to believe this is a tournament anymore.
This is a psychology experiment.
A declining mental capacity of a typical streamer.
I refuse to believe.
I think he's fireball boy.
He's coming for us!
He's coming for us.
But they're all faster than me.
He's coming.
I'm so scared.
You guys are all good Minecraft players.
Oh my god.
What?
He's so loud.
They're all better players than me.
No, Axxo, no!
They're faster than me.
Axxo, run!
No, Axxo!
They're all faster than me.
Help!
He's like a lion.
I don't hear it.
He's still there.
No, I messed up the stairs.
I messed up the stairs, guys.
I messed up the stairs.
He's right there.
Bro, there's nothing.
Axxo, no!
Axxo is right there!
Oh, he's behind.
He's still behind.
He's still right behind.
I hear something.
I don't like him.
Okay, okay, okay.
You lived in my dreams.
Stay.
Relocate my fantasy.
I stay reality.
You made my dreams.
Stay.
She was a broken, kind, Oh my god...
What the fuck?
Run, run, run, run, run!
It's on us, it's on us, it's on us, it's on us!
It's right there!
IT'S RIGHT THERE!
It's right there, it's right there!
I'm so scared, I'm so scared, I'm so scared...
Ow!
Five up!
Help!
Please!
Oh, please!
Let's kill somebody!
That's mental torture!
Oh my god!
Just give us money for this!
I don't care!
We deserve money for doing this!
The sick entertainment for viewers!
It keeps doing that!
We deserve money for this!
Oh my god!
I can't be confident!
This is so sad!
We deserve to be rewarded!
I don't care if we get punished for this!
I don't care!
Not you guys!
The sick entertainment for viewers!
You deserve kind of that $30,000!
Oh, ha, ha, ha, ha...
We can't mute guys, we have to listen to no one, we have to run.
That's the worst part.
We have to run.
It's either light blue or brown.
Yeah they are, they're basically the Pixar seagulls.
I'll try and turn it down again.
Dude this game is lasting way too much.
I did not expect us to lose this long.
How many people need to die?
Three?
Three more.
I feel like the remainder of people are going to die.
Goodbye, this is it.
I can feel it.
This has to be it, this has to be it.
Please.
Please just kill me.
Just take me out.
Please.
Just like instantly run at me.
I don't care.
Run!
Just instantly run at me.
And stab me in the heart.
Is it coming?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stab me in the heart.
It's coming.
Don't stop, don't stop, don't stop.
Don't stop.
Believe in me.
Instantly stab me please.
Hold on to my feelings.
Oh my god.
You were so close.
You walked through.
It was literally right here.
Was it right here?
I don't believe it.
I think so.
No, this one is really close.
Oh my god.
This one is...
We should stop this one.
We should just stop thinking of this one.
I think we have to go through every single one of them now.
That's the last one.
The other guy, Axel.
He's my friend, my friend.
Yes, yes.
I met him.
No, there's no...
He's dying.
Siren, siren, siren, siren, siren.
Siren, siren, siren, siren.
Alright, this is where I die.
Just run at me.
Stab me, that's all I want.
Just stab me.
Put me out of my misery.
I'm being hunted.
Is it coming?
Yes or no?
Is it?
Question mark?
I don't think any of them followed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One followed once.
Oh my god, I thought it was gonna be hunting me.
I thought it was it.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
We shouldn't run.
We should stay in the corner.
Is it behind us?
I don't know, but it's somewhere.
It's not behind us.
It's not here.
Why would we move from a place that's...
Let's hold the corner.
Hit me, hit me, hit me.
Come, come, come.
We can hold the corner.
It's fine.
Oh man, I don't trust that spot, guys.
Watch that side.
I'm gonna watch the side.
I mean, I got it.
It's hunting you from over here, so...
This is so sad.
I got one earlier.
That's why I wanted to go...
Groups are shrinking, man.
This is scary.
Oh, there's a group coming over here?
Question mark?
Let's get, let's get.
Running from the other end.
Oh yeah, it's right here, it's right here.
It's right in front of me, it's right in front of me.
It's chilling, it's chilling.
Just circling around.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Don't scream, don't scream.
Wait, there's one here as well.
There's one here as well.
Don't scream.
Okay, let's go that way.
They turned around, they turned around.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Stay near the other crab.
Remember guys, just don't die and everything will be fine.
Wolfie, just stay back here.
You're good.
Oh, he is behind us.
Wow.
He hit my butt.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Okay, okay, okay.
He is right behind me.
Oh no, this is it, this is it, guys.
This is it, I'm the slowest.
I don't know the tech, I don't know the tech.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, guys.
I don't know the running tech.
It is right behind us.
I don't know.
I don't know the running tech.
This is it.
Oh, got me.
Go, T lect envolves you.
Wow.
Where was she?
You got her.
Gummy, Gummy, run.
We had a good run.
We had such a good run, everybody !
We had such a good run, everyone!
We had an insane run, everybody, but this is it.
This is it.
It was worth a shot.
Yeah, I think so.
What the mid-wing?
Is it still behind us?
You got me there.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, I never managed to get there.
Throw in fireballs.
Oh my god.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, right.
Uh-oh.
I just want somebody to turn around and just take it.
This is a good lap.
This is a good loop.
We can run.
Yeah, oh my god.
This is not even like hide anymore.
It's just run.
No, I'm safe.
I'm safe.
It's just...
No, I'm safe.
It's not even hide and seek.
We're just...
It's like a marathon run.
We're just doing a marathon right now.
Oh my god.
Turn, turn, turn, turn, turn.
Turn around, turn around, turn around.
Oh my god.
I think I'm done.
Marathon!
Turn around, turn around.
I'm scared.
Every now and then I fall apart.
And I'm gonna be a liar.
I'm scared.
This is not good.
We got to converge with those guys.
We screwed up.
Oh, come on.
We did not screw up.
Oh, here it is.
This sacrifice.
Goodbye, funny guy, if you want to.
This is it.
It would be so poetic that I got eliminated last person.
As the last person I get eliminated right away.
It would be so poetic though.
Oh my god.
After going through like the entire round.
The stressful day.
I am the last person to be out.
It would be so poetic.
After everything we've been through.
Guys, green is not going to happen.
Green is not going to happen.
I'm going to be honest.
I'm not going tolife completely.
No, why does it have to be saved?
Why?
Say it to the moon .
I don't care, it's just not there.
Just no matter what, it's just not there.
Yeah, she is still alive.
Whatever.
That's not good.
I just don't want to be here.
The round is going to be safe.
We have to be brave and get our clothes on.
We are not going to have to pick this one anyways.
Maybe it doesn't matter what we're picking.
We're going to pick the things we want.
Pfft.
This is the line.
Oh my god.
Don't be safe.
Why does he keep screaming?
Who is this?
Call the streamer out right now to me.
And I will specifically meet that person in voice chat if I live.
Is it?
Oh my god.
Okay, I have power.
Okay, well there's just one dog left.
What's the point?
What's the point of safe dolls, bro?
Where is he?
Oh wait, I got the wrong one.
Whoops.
Sorry.
It's meaningless.
We're all meant to die anyway.
Red guys don't die.
Sorry.
Oh my god, bro.
Thank you for the tier one.
I'm going through hell right now.
This is it.
Goodbye, everybody.
It was a good run.
It was a good run, everyone.
I had a...
Run, run, run!
It was a good run.
I had a great time in here with everybody.
It was such a good run that like...
Guys, we win or not?
We win or not?
We had such a good run.
We had such a good run and this is it.
This is where we...
This is where we call it.
Guys, if it says that it's targeting you, you have to jump inside one of those hiding places.
If you don't do it, it's gonna kill you.
Just so you know.
I was targeted last time.
That's insane.
I was hunted in a crowd.
GG!
No way!
Who was?
Who died?
GG!
No...
Are we the last six in our room, guys?
Oh my god!
I think so.
I think we all have a set spawn room.
No, no, no.
This is the pain that never ends.
I think this one was the worst one.
30 people.
30 people are going to get eliminated in the next one.
It's the prop hunt game.
Wait, Iroh got eliminated?
Oh my god.
To be fair, I was surprised that he lived this long.
I was just as stressed.
Oh my god.
I need to be in a corner.
I need to... wait.
Okay, that's cool.
Give me a sec, guys.
Oh my god.
Let me turn down the...
Wait, voice chat would be...
Okay, give me a sec.
I actually need a tiny reset myself.
Thank god.
I feel like they should have play tested that game.
Devlin, thank you for the 100 biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so sorry for the voices, guys.
I couldn't take my meds, guys.
We needed intel.
I'm so...
I'm so sorry for the screaming earlier.
Bro, I'm so tired.
That one game exhausted me.
Oh my god.
That one fucking game actually exhausted me.
I actually had to mute somebody.
I was like, no, bro.
If this is a Stanford prison experiment, bro, I'm fucking...
Let me out.
Let me out of that prison.
The voices were so strong.
Oh my god.
All that for 10 people to be eliminated.
That's the worst part.
Only 10 people were eliminated.
At least experiment subjects got paid.
Bro, I should get paid.
I should get paid for like the mental toll that took out of me.
It was good content.
Yeah, the next game is 30.
Bro, those puppets should have killed 20 people.
I don't understand.
Instead, they should have got a goddamn double kill.
Instead, they put us through hell.
They put us through hell for sick entertainment.
Bro, it's just a game.
Oh my god.
It might be just a game.
But my...
I felt like I just aged another 50 years playing this game.
Nobody gets paid until day 5.
The content of winning.
I was actually going crazy.
I was going goddamn crazy.
I thought I was going to turn into Joker.
I thought...
I thought I was going to turn into Joker right there.
Oh my god.
Oh, but it's over.
Day 10.
Game 2.
Prop hunt.
Yeah.
I'm going to die so fast as a prop.
Guys, knowing my luck, I'm going to get prop.
I'm going to get like...
Insta...
Insta fucking ganked by a hunter.
Jokey bird is coming back.
I had to mute.
I can't...
I can't listen to the voices anymore.
I can't.
Guys.
Are they doing a...
Are they looking at a funeral for their friend?
Oh, they are.
Holy shit.
Oh
my God.
I got it.
Okay, I don't think they're friends.
I don't... guys, I... I don't think that... I don't think that was... that was a friend, guys.
That was... that was definitely not for a friend.
Hello... hello... I'm here... I'm here...
Yeah, you made it.
I made it.
Were you ever hunted?
Yeah, I was hunted.
That means you didn't die.
All my other friends died.
This is helligumi.
That last game was hell.
I don't know if you're gonna like the next game anymore.
I think the next game's harder.
Yeah...
Me was a good run, Gumi.
Get to day four for me, Gumi.
I believe in you.
I believe in you, Gumi.
Live on for me.
Live on.
If you're a hunter and I'm a prop, I'll give you that one point, Gumi.
I don't know how to find you.
You'll know it's me.
You go into a room and you see a prop moving.
That's me.
You take that one point.
You take that one point and take it over the day for it, Gumi.
But we don't know how it's gonna be like.
It's basically... it's like a one for all.
That's what you said.
Maybe.
I don't know.
It can't be team.
It feels bad.
What?
Abe died because his game crashed.
Wait, really?
That's why he died?
You know what's funny?
Abe was like, we should sacrifice Doki to the monster.
And then he died like ten seconds later.
Dude, I'll be honest.
I was so ready to sacrifice any random that I saw.
Oh my god, nothing's chasing us.
Bro, I just wanted it to be over.
That shit was so stressful.
Like, the safe dolls...
Did you F5?
No, I didn't.
I just followed the crowd.
The safe zones didn't matter.
I did understand the safe dolls.
So, it didn't matter.
It was just until we got rid of all the dolls.
Yeah.
And ten people.
The safe zones actually did nothing.
Yeah, it did nothing.
It just prolonged the game.
Yeah.
And like, we had to choose all the dolls anyway.
So like, what's the point?
Yeah, and then like, even like, and then there's always majority.
Majority wins.
So like, it doesn't matter what we choose.
Illusion of choice of illusion.
Yeah, and then one guy was screaming at the top of his... I muted that guy.
There was one...
Who's it?
Tell me.
Oh, you're gonna mute him too?
Yeah, it's the sap guy.
I know who you're talking about.
Yeah, I muted him.
I was like, chat, tell me who it is.
I can't.
But I cannot hear him yell at me, yell at everybody anymore.
Oh no, yeah, I kept muting until like, it got mid-round just to hear if someone's coming or not.
Yeah, I like, kept it on the entire time because I was so scared.
I was so scared that I was gonna die.
No, I was like, kind of getting pissed off.
Oh no, I was just crying.
I was crying.
Like, I feel like loud does not equal funny, so I was just getting it wrong.
Yeah, it was just not funny.
Like, unless you say something funny, but they weren't saying anything funny.
This is the person I lied to on day one.
I feel bad.
This one?
Rest in peace.
I don't.
I learned that from, I learned that from the Spanish people.
I unmuted and they were spitting at somebody's grave.
Yeah, yeah, I was like, oh look, they're paying respect to their dead friend.
And then I unmuted, and it was just a group of people, like, spitting on his grave.
I was like, oh, I don't think that's a friend.
I don't...
Yeah, I'm watering the grass a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
A VTuber lived longer than you.
Oh shit, wait, we're on the same channel!
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry, Eva.
Sorry, sorry, we're sorry, we're sorry.
We're sorry.
Okay, are we off yet?
She's watering the flowers, man.
We're watering the flowers, we're watering the flowers.
Who's next?
Okay, that's not me, guys, that's not me.
They heard all of it, Gumi.
We're just paying respect by help making sure the flowers.
Yeah, we're watering the flowers.
Yeah.
See, Mendo has no flowers.
Yeah, yeah, because nobody paid respect to him.
How are we doing, guys?
Scared, but confident?
Yeah.
Who's next?
We're making sure, we're making sure that they're hydrated.
Oh, this one I can't spit on, I'm going to throw it back on the floor.
Oh, we gotta say goodbye to Gumi.
Me too.
I don't know who they are, but I will too.
We're gonna say goodbye to the red velvet.
I didn't mean to say goodbye to Gumi.
Oh, no.
We gotta say goodbye to red velvet.
I don't remember the rest.
I don't know who this person is, but 07.
Is this the guy that you were talking about?
You don't like this guy?
No, this guy didn't even follow me back on Twitter.
Damn!
Who is this guy?
Wait, did he get out in this last game?
No, yesterday.
I was gonna say, we had a run from the beast, but surely you'd think Sonic would be fast.
Clearly not.
Oh!
No, they lost in the task one.
The puzzle, quote on quote.
Damn.
So he might be fast with his feet, but he's not fast with his brain.
Oh!
Oh my god, look, it's me!
I see you!
And dead bodies to the left and right of you.
Yeah, all my friends are freaking dead.
No, they're still... Bear!
Bear's still alive!
Mr. Bear!
Yeah, Wally's still alive.
Where's your grave, Doki?
Mine's all the way back here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it alphabetical?
Yeah, yeah, so I get the front.
Shay, wanna hear something funny?
Doki hard-muted Sapnap.
That's funny.
I think it's so funny.
I mean, I don't blame you.
He was screaming!
I was like, I clearly can't focus!
During the last game...
Yeah?
Oh, you muted him during the last game?
Yeah, during the last game I muted him.
I was like, chat, who is this guy?
He's the person that keeps yelling!
And everybody just said, you're that guy.
So, that might have been my fault because I had a strategy and he was like right next to me and I knew people would listen to him because he just screams.
Yeah?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Eight people get selected.
Oh, so you have to like survive and you get points and you complete tasks and you get points.
Don't mind!
What are these?
Oh, you respawn if you're a hunter as a pro.
Bro, what the heck?
This rules is like an essay.
They'll show a video, man.
They'll show you a video.
Monsters upon respawning.
Monsters will still be monsters.
Players will be able to select a monster class which they will want to play next.
What?
That's what I'm saying!
It's a goddamn essay!
Maybe.
So, my best thing I'd say is obviously try to complete tasks but I'd say try to get those survival points because it might come down to just simple points.
Yeah.
Wait, so what do you mean by it's your fault?
What did you do?
So, basically the way that last game worked is whatever color got picked, that's where they would start spawning.
So, I wanted them to spawn on the opposite side so we had as much time to run and Sapnep was the person to my right so I was like, Sapnep, just get them all to pick the other side.
You made that!
It was you!
It was you all along!
I'm sorry!
Alright, I'm sorry.
My chat had to pay for my therapy for that game!
My bad, my bad, my bad.
Oh my god, it was him!
He was the mastermind!
As a hunter, you just get points for killing someone but you don't want to hit the wrong people because then you lose points.
Divide into two groups props and hunters And then it just leaves my points to get eliminated.
Start as hunters with the remaining...
Oh my god, there's so much reading!
Each round, eight participants start as hunters while the remaining will start as props.
A total of four rounds of playing elimination will occur after all rounds have been played.
Rounds will be randomly selected.
If a player dies, they will have a cooldown before they may respawn.
Props become monsters upon respawning.
While as monsters, there will still be monsters in both cases.
Players will be able to select which they want to play next.
Each group has specific game objectives they must achieve as...
Oh my god!
Ah!
Bro!
That's... okay.
Props gameplay.
As props, players must survive as much as possible.
If a player survives for at least five minutes during a set round, the player will earn points.
Props can activate door locks to help running from the hunters but there's a point penalty by each.
Props will also be given four quests to complete.
Upon completing a quest, the player can earn special items and will also earn points.
Props can solidify on other objects by pressing F at positions they would like.
They can also ship ship each other objects by clicking at them.
Prop disguise includes but are not limited to skulls, kennels, holders, pots, statues, chairs, etc.
An anti-AFK system is applied to the game, making props visible to everyone if they stay in the same position for 60 seconds.
The AFK debuff will be removed once the player moves at least four blocks away from the position.
If a prop is defeated by a hunter...
There's more?
Okay guys, there's like an elimination paragraph as well.
Hahahaha As hunters, players will have to select one out of three available hunting classes, each ummm each possessing different abilities.
They can be used every few minutes to give them some advantage.
These can be selected at the start of each round and also hunters must defeat as many props as possible.
Defeating a prop will give you a point.
Hunters must pay close attention before striking objects.
Once hitting regular will have deals they will die.
Participate all rounds or government.
Survive ten minutes plus two points.
Complete a task plus five.
Defeat a prop plus five points.
Incorrect prop hit minus two.
Alright.
Okay.
I read a lot of that.
Alright guys.
We gotta be in emote only mode.
Emote only mode.
I finished reading two.
That was like three goddamn pages.
That was like a goddamn essay.
Good luck guys.
I hope you make it to day four Gumi.
Rest in peace Gun Teddy.
Rest in peace.
Rest in peace funny guy.
I'll never know actually how funny you were.
Huh?
You say something I was peeing.
Okay.
Gumi.
I believe in you to make it to day four.
Do it for me.
Do it for everybody.
Do it for our fans.
Okay.
Just do...
Try to do more tasks than surviving.
Okay.
I think it's gonna come down to points.
Yeah.
I'll try my best.
This will be the last time we can talk.
Oh.
Okay.
Nevermind.
We can still talk.
Oh yeah.
Do you put emote only mode?
Yeah.
I'm about to.
They said in general that they need to ensure everyone is in it.
Ah.
Yeah.
I put mine in just now.
Oh my god.
What a freaking diabolical plan.
To use sap for that.
That shit actually made me crazy.
My chat and I were like mentally drained.
I actually didn't hear the plan.
Oh.
Basically, what he did...
What your friend did was that he convinced sap to yell as loud as he can to convince people to go on the other side of the map.
So like...
Him and their friends would be like on the other side.
So the monster...
The puppet would chase the people on the majority of the...
of the colors.
So like the people on the other side get to have like a free run.
Like a free... uh...
Free reset, I guess.
Ah, I see.
So yeah, he convinced sap to like yell as loud as he can to put everybody in one square while their group were on the other opposite side.
And that was so evil.
I can't believe us spitting on E-Rob's grave was on the main channel.
I can't believe.
Dude, why did he put that on the main channel?
Yeah!
We were doing so many other things!
We were doing so many things like feeding the orphans, watering flowers, helping cats out of trees.
We were like showing people where the eggs are and everything.
Being a good citizen.
And then they show us spitting on E-Rob's grave.
I can't believe it.
This is like...
Propaganda.
Propaganda?
Why did you use that word?
It's negative propaganda against us.
It's slander!
Oh my god.
This is the longest five seconds in the world.
That's crazy that they have to check each individual stream if we're in emo only mode.
You were wrong.
It's easier to be a prop in this game mode.
Why?
Oh, to get tasks.
Yeah.
What with the new points?
Because I thought they were gonna...
Yeah?
Because the hunters get minus two points if they hit something wrong.
Yeah.
That's true.
So it's kind of doomed.
I'm just thinking how...
There's so many props too.
What if it's just a hitbox?
You know?
Like the messed up hitbox that freaks you up.
Freaks you up.
Yeah.
So I think everybody should get a chance to play hunter once, right?
Or is it like...
It could be RNG though.
Yeah, it's RNG.
Yeah.
But then when you die as a prop, you get respawned as a hunter.
So we have to also hunt as a prop.
As we die.
Right?
Unless I misread it.
Huh?
I wasn't listening.
I said if we get caught as a prop, we have to hunt after that.
Yeah, you become a hunter next.
Yeah, so it's just like living as long as you can, doing tasks.
Yeah.
I just...
There were so many words.
There were so many...
It's okay, they're gonna play a video.
Thank god.
The video will help a lot.
I need the visuals.
I need my coco melon.
Please.
Coco melon.
To be fair, the video on the last game was not helpful at all.
Because it implied that you're safe.
That it's not majority.
I didn't even say that in the rules either.
Yeah.
I...
It was a time It would've been helpful knowing the dolls had abilities and showing which doll had what ability.
Like the fireball kind.
Yeah.
I feel like this game is really well coded though.
It's well coded, but I feel like they should've tested the games more.
Like, I feel like there's so many things that could've been adjusted if the games were tested a little bit more.
Like the tiebreaker one.
Do you remember the tiebreaker on day one?
And how there's barely enough time for people to do the tiebreaker.
If they got cursed.
Stuff like that.
I got the info about that.
Apparently you can see the person who's cursed, but you can't see the people who aren't cursed.
It's like the other thing.
Oh, so like the people who are cursed don't even know where they are.
No, but here Dokia, I'll teach you a trick.
If you play F5 and you just run around like this, you can scan around the area better.
Oh.
People keep telling me to play F5, but like, I'm so bad at moving when it comes to F5.
Play.
Monsters earn...
Monsters earn five points by killing props.
You don't lose points for doing a puzzle incorrectly.
If you die by killing a false prop as a hunter, you have to respawn.
Respawn timers are 120 seconds.
Wait, that's a lot.
Dying is bad.
60 seconds in fourth round.
Holy...
Oh, wow.
Wait, that's...
Dying is just bad.
Yeah, I agree.
That's like so long.
Might as well just stand still.
Well, there's the timer.
60 seconds AFK timer.
Oh, true.
But still, I feel like...
Wait, hold on.
Let's go discuss with my Minecraft friends.
Yeah, that's true.
We should have been talking about strats with them.
Well, I guess we do have to play F5 chat because it's a prop, so we have to know where people are.
It doesn't say anything about losing points.
You just gotta... Like, when you die as a prop, you become a hunter, so you just gotta stay locked in no matter what you are, honestly.
Like, either do your tasks or go for prop kills.
Gumi!
Hi!
Did you guys see the TV below the table?
Made you look.
Yeah, I don't believe you.
Evil.
I'm not helping you next time.
I looked.
I'm not gonna lie.
I didn't look.
This one over here looks like a TV.
I believe it.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm coming.
I'm alright.
I feel like this is the one I get out.
Already discussing strats?
Hey, what's the strat?
The strat is to do a speedrun, depending on the map.
You speedrun the tasks.
That's what I thought, yeah.
And then you int.
And then you become a hunter, so you can get the points.
Because, like, you don't really get many minuses.
You just need to be careful as a hunter to not hit the wrong things.
I would only ever hit something if you see it moving, honestly.
Really?
You want to try to survive?
No, because it's only two points for survival.
But, like, if you get hit, you just die.
It's five points for kill, and it's only two for survival every five minutes.
You get so many more points for killing.
Did you see the message they sent in general chat?
That the respawn timer is 120 seconds for the first two rounds or three rounds?
So, if you can speedrun your tasks fast and then die, you can probably get a hunter within, like, five minutes-ish when you respawn, and you can just get a lot of points killing people.
And they can't do anything because they're on respawn.
I mean, depending on, like, how far you want to, like, try and game the system.
I wonder if, like, props have, like, certain speeds, just like prop hunt.
I assume it's going to be, like, that we all move, like, the same amount of speed, where you have to move a little faster.
I feel like hunters should move faster, honestly.
Like, the smaller the prop you are, the faster you can be.
But you have less HP.
Yeah, I want to know, like, how much HP you have with, like, large things, or if it's, like, one hit.
Yeah, because I feel like large items should have more HP.
Skull, lantern, like, candle, chair, and something else, right?
There's only a couple of small things.
Like, it would be things like this, I think.
Oh my god, there's a squad of FBI.
Bro, they're fucking walking like a squad.
It's like, Mr. President, get down.
Mr. President, get down.
What the heck?
Are they real people?
Are those real people?
Like, what the?
They're so coordinated.
What if we say, like, right now, we're going to turn into, like, a very specific item, like a skull.
Right, and just don't want to do this.
I think I want to turn into...
Yeah, a skull probably would be the easiest.
Either the skull or, like, the...
There was another small one they mentioned.
Candles?
Yeah, candles.
There's chairs, too.
I haven't seen a lot of chairs here, though.
It's like...
Yeah, I mean, I was looking at the... those chairs over there are, like, sort of big.
Like, the ones in the kitchen.
Like, those are massive.
Yeah.
I wonder what would be, like, the best spot to, like, hide.
I'm just...
I wonder what the tasks are.
I hope they're, like, not... I hope the tasks are, like, somewhat easy.
Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
I mean, four tasks in ten minutes has got to be easier.
Yeah, but then I'm, like, wondering if they're going to be, like, divided into different rooms.
You're going to see, like, props running around everywhere trying to get to various rooms.
Yeah.
It's also going to be, like, because there's three different types of monsters with different powers, but we don't know what that is.
Like, if there's one that just has, like, a sensor there's a monster in the room, you just stay AFK in that room for a minute and wait for them to move.
I think it could be one that gives you, like, a speed boost.
One that maybe helps you find props that are hidden.
And one that... I don't know what the third one could be, but...
Maybe, like, a range ability or some kind.
Cool.
Oh my gosh.
Finally the timer started!
Yay!
And then on the... like, let's say you're in a tie.
It's a free-for-all deathmatch.
So you just, like, want to be with your ally if you have any in there.
Yeah.
Wouldn't the tiebreaker be only one person survive out of everybody?
Well, like, the bottom 30 people.
So, like, let's say multiple people have the same amount of points in the bottom 30.
It's like, I think we'll see a tiebreaker.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get knocked out.
Parkour time.
Oh my god.
This is not RNG.
This is actually tryhard time.
Yeah, right?
This is not fair.
What happened to the RNG?
Yeah.
We made it this far, guys.
We made it to Day 3.
Nah, we gotta be Day 5 Warlord.
All four of us.
All four of us?
Okay.
I don't know what kind of copium you have.
Guys, if you guys win, give me $1,000, please.
Please.
I'll say it right here, right now.
I'll be shameless.
I want $1,000.
Only if you do the same.
Okay, fine.
I will.
I will, actually.
I promise.
I'll give you guys points if... Wait, no.
That's colluding.
I was gonna say, I'll give you guys points if you split the money.
Okay.
If you guys make it to the top 20...
If you guys make it...
I'll give you guys points if you guys split your cash earnings.
If you make it to the top 20.
Shining.
Look.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
You want me to get the video?
Oh, I'm hunted.
I'm hunted.
Die, die, die.
Help.
Guys, we're waiting to start.
We're still waiting?
There's more rules?
They posted more rules.
How are there more rules?
Bro, okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me read this.
Okay.
You don't lose points for doing any monsters.
Earn 5 points by killing props.
Do not get killed as a prop in any round unless you base on points by the end of round 4.
We will count steps taken for hunters.
What?
We count steps taken?
You will not spawn as...
You start as a hunter in round 1.
You will not...
Okay.
Alright.
I swear I registered this.
I was like, how is there more?
I was so surprised.
I was like, there's more to read?
I'm crouching up and down in the corner.
Okay.
What is this?
This is it.
Guys, I feel like...
Guys, I feel like when I'm a hunter, I have to play in first person.
I think as a hunter, I would absolutely accidentally hit other things if I wasn't first person.
Because I don't play enough Minecraft to realize where the
hitboxes are.
Like, I'm so bad with hitboxes.
Where are the hunters?
That's what I think too.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Please show me the video of what the task is.
I wanna know what the task is.
Being a hunter first round is also great because you don't know the map and how it's playing out.
Me, personally, if I'm a runner, I'm gonna play and just get a feel for everything.
I'm gonna do my tasks and everything because those are high points.
I'm just gonna play passive and get a feel for how aggressive everything is.
Stealing intel.
Adjust and see.
Stealing strats right now.
It wouldn't matter anyway because I don't know what I'm doing.
I feel like these Minecraft players know more than me.
Thanks for the free intel.
Loser.
But not really a loser because they might have a chance from... they might have a chance of winning $70,000 because they play this game more.
But still.
Thanks for revealing your strats.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
We made it.
Wait, we all have one bar?
Woah!
Wait.
What the heck?
Someone's chat was like we all have one bar.
They kicked this out?
Oh, because...
That would be awkward.
Okay, now it's okay.
That was crazy.
Someone in the chat was like everybody has one bar and then we all got kicked out.
Guys, I think they started the server like on the opposite side of the world.
On the opposite side of NA.
I'm pretty sure.
NA and SA.
I think they started the server in like Japan or something.
Because why did all of us get one bar?
That was crazy.
They're going to fix the server.
Okay, they're going to move us again soon.
My heart, man.
This has been the most stressful rest week of my life.
Hey.
Made it.
Oh, Doki.
I got some bad news.
Yeah, what's the bad news?
We all discussed it.
We're going to target you.
Wait, what?
Why me?
Yeah, I'm not going to but they all want to.
Wait, what?
What did I do?
They just want you out.
What?
Apparently you're too good and Gumi said she was gunning for you.
Okay, now I know you're lying.
Gumi would never throw me out.
You're lying.
We have a pact.
Gumi would never.
Oh my god.
I'm telling Gumi this.
It's true.
Where is Gumi?
Gumi would never.
She would never wrap me up.
Gumi would never do such a thing.
Wait, where is she?
I gotta buy an account.
What?
Someone said I gotta buy an account.
Are you going to win?
Alright, where is she?
I'm gonna ride him out.
It's over.
It's over for him.
Gumi would never.
She would never do such a thing to me.
Also, like, how do you target people anyway?
Like, you can't even see any.
You're literally a prop.
That's messed up.
That breaks rule 33.
No neg...
No negative behavior.
That breaks rule 33.
This has to be a positive...
Oh, wait.
I broke rule 33 when I was on the main broadcast.
Whoops.
Oopsie.
It's okay.
It was in...
It was like...
like a positive thing that happened there.
Where is she?
I don't know where she is.
Where did she go?
That was actually crazy.
I realized a lot of Minecraft players died during the first game.
Which is insane to think about for me.
I don't know.
I actually think it's like actually crazy that I lived longer than a lot of like...
uh...
a lot of the well-known Minecraft players in this game.
Yeah, respawn hunters should not get points.
That's just how it should go.
Yeah.
Oh, they're angry about the rules.
They're angry about the rules.
They're angry.
There is things that need to be done.
It's a little silly.
There's like...
It's definitely like speed running and then dying.
It's just depending on like how hard the tasks are.
And if you're able to do them all.
Yeah.
A lot of question marks.
I think the cinematic will give a few of those questions answers, but...
Yeah, that's the thing.
I think some people are tweaking about the rules, but I feel like the cinematic will make it so much more simpler.
It also depends on the power of the monster.
Yep.
Oh my god, I'm listening.
I'm seeing the strats.
Oh my god.
I hear people complaining.
And I gotta steal the strats.
Oh, big time.
Big time.
I gotta steal the strats from the speed runners.
From the Minecraft speed runners gamers.
You're my sunflower.
Momon makes it so...
Oh, is that the remaining Spanish players?
Is that it?
I thought there was more.
There must be more.
I'm pretty sure.
You know what?
There's 80 of us.
They must have been separated into other groups.
I'm just trying to find Gumi so I can rat bad boy out.
Can't believe it.
I almost believed him until he said Gumi threw me under the bus.
After everything she did, there was no way she would throw me under the bus.
She already wasted so much time, like, dragging me through the finish line for so many days.
Why stop now?
She dragged me to the finish line.
So why would she stop now?
That's when I knew he was lying.
Oh my god.
Is she just AFK?
I don't even feel like I haven't bumped into her at all.
Guys, yay or nay?
Is she AFK?
Or is she actually moving around so that I couldn't...
I just barely missed her.
She's not?
Okay.
I'm just unlucky.
Yeah, that's actually crazy.
Alright, let's try this just to do task.
I'm just unlucky.
What the heck?
Where could she have gone?
Wait, is that... no?
There's only two people outside.
Oh my god.
This is a harder hide and seek than the actual hide and seek game.
This is actually a harder hide and seek game.
Now I'm playing the real mini game.
Find Goomy.
For example, you know the TNT tag game that they played to get people out?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everyone could be running at the same speed.
Bro, that's what I thought for the game.
They weren't.
So...
Intel.
Just gotta be sneaky.
Just wanted the Intel.
You know what?
They're doing?
They're actual Minecraft players.
Wanted to know.
A minute and a half.
Jesus.
That's so long.
Are they on this side?
No.
Goomy!
You weren't throwing me under the bus, right?
Goomy?
How would I throw you under the bus?
Badboy was saying everybody was gonna throw me under the bus, including you.
But I didn't believe it.
I didn't believe it because I was like, Goomy would never.
I would never.
Not after how much...
That's what I said!
I was like, there's no way!
Goomy dragged me to the finish line.
Why would she throw me under now?
Badboy's a liar.
Don't trust him.
He tried to scare me.
He tried to tell me.
He's such a bad boy.
Badboys!
Oh my god.
I'm just looking for eggs though.
Because I feel like...
It takes so long.
Yeah, but it doesn't matter though.
The eggs do nothing.
You don't know that.
What if they give you 20 million subs if you get all of them first?
Okay, but you gotta live to the last day.
Nah, I'd win.
Because like, every day they add 10 more eggs, so...
What if they gift everyone 20 million?
Oh no, they can't be pleased.
And they paste in the traduction...
If they did that, then like...
Then like, I'd rather they just...
I'd rather they just split the 70k to the other days.
Instead of that.
No, I feel that too.
Is this...
Yeah, I found absolutely nothing.
You found 20 million eggs?
He's my friend, not your friend.
I have 28.
I heard that they like, activate the eggs late too, sometimes.
Say he that you're my friend.
Oh, I heard that too.
Yeah, yeah, because someone in the general chat like, activated the...
He said the final egg was activated after...
I'm a better friend than him.
After half the...
The day was over.
Yeah, that's so int.
That's so... That's messed up.
That's Ashley messed up.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
You know, if a non-Minecraft player makes it to day four, that's a goddamn win in my book.
Well, there's a lot of non-Minecraft players.
No, there is... You know damn well the majority of the players here that are live aren't Minecraft players.
The one that Red died to was like the fast one.
Like it was like super speed.
Like super fast or something.
So I guess that's like a thing.
Okay, I'm coming.
Did you ever hide in the...
No, because they were saying that they camped people.
Oh, I hid in one.
Wait, did it work?
Well, it was busy chasing someone else.
Oh.
I didn't hide because like people were saying that like the puppet was camping people outside.
Really?
Oh, that's scary.
Yeah, so then I didn't hide.
So I got scared.
Good luck.
Good luck, everybody.
If you see me, run into me as a prop.
I will.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's go back in my house.
Alright, now we're not one by.
Oh, wait a minute.
We're not one by now.
Everybody to the other edge of the corner so you don't...
You can only start as a hunter one round.
Oh, good tech.
Interesting.
How do you know that?
And there's a two minute respawn.
It is.
Yeah, read general chat.
They gave a lot of tips.
Wait, what was the...
You can peek.
What do you think?
Um...
You are my friend.
Wow, he's a Naruto enjoyer?
You are...
I'm listening to the intel.
You are my friend.
Yeah.
I don't know the lyrics.
We've been in emote mode.
For like years now.
Only two hours have passed.
I swear.
I feel like...
I feel like I've been trapped in this purgatory.
For like eight years.
Since day one.
Since day one I've been in purgatory.
For eight years.
And it's not gonna be me.
I love Minecraft.
I...
I love Minecraft!
Right, voice chat will be...
voice chat will be gone soon, guys.
Yeah.
I feel like...
I feel like one of those like pets.
that have their life span extended I've been extended for like way too long.
You know what I mean?
By like ultra rich like owners and they extend their pets lifespan to like...
Longer than they should have been alive in this event.
And Gumi's the owner.
Gumi has extended my lifespan to the point where like...
It should not be possible for me to be here.
I should not... I'm like blind in both eyes like crawling right now.
I need to wear a diaper.
I'm like please.
I can't... am I still... am I still alive?
What?
Keep the respawn timer.
No that's if you die as a hunter.
Oh!
I see.
Rob to hunter.
Yes!
No problem, no problem.
It's reduced.
They said it was reduced like...
Rob turning to a hunter.
Oh!
That's messed up.
That is crazy.
Why can't he hear that?
I'll run into my first friend and look up to him and use a prop.
I know for a fact because I've read all this out loud.
Oh my god.
They said somewhere me and Wally noticed that.
Yeah.
You are my friend.
Where are like the non Minecraft players still alive?
It's like...
It's me.
It is.
We can't say Gumi because she plays a lot of Minecraft.
Like she plays exponentially a lot amount... large amount.
She's part of like at least two different Minecraft servers.
Like at least two.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You guys can't talk to me.
So yeah.
I don't even know.
I'm talking to myself.
I'm actually curious who's like not a Minecraft player that's still alive.
You get five points from finishing a task and you get five points per kill.
So the faster you become a hunter you know.
Yeah.
That's true.
I think it's when they said that everybody's doing it then like there's gonna be less people to kill anyway.
That's my problem.
So far what we've seen is very open.
But I assume past the corridors it'll be...
Can you approach for a second?
I don't know guys.
I'm scared.
Dude your ass is out.
I'm scared too.
Yeah.
Can you approach for three?
Last 30.
Okay I'm wrong.
Five minutes.
Another five?
I know we can't sing a song but can we make up a song together?
Yeah I'm associated with the normal hunter respawn period.
Uh I'm curious if that's right.
Oh wait.
Do we have to increase that on our own as well or?
See I feel like when we were singing the clapping hands song it was feeling good.
It was making my hair and teeth so dry like .
I don't know if I know but I think doing tasks and then dying quickly is actually moving us.
If you're happy in all the classes.
That was good.
Who did that?
Yeah.
The one you talked about.
Okay!
If you're happy and you know it, if you really want to show it, if you're happy and you know it, keep fighting for your plans.
I feel like we're trying to cope.
See, that made me feel better.
Anyone else?
I feel better.
I feel lighter.
I feel a little lighter.
I feel like we're inhaling some copium at the moment.
We're gaslighting each other.
It's not gone.
There's two left.
Look, just remember this.
If you die...
In the game, you die in your life.
In real life!
Exactly!
Guys, I'm gonna die in real life.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
I've... I've lived through enough.
Oh, thank God.
Wait, again?
I used... Oh my God!
Just eliminate me now!
Just... Just elim... Just take me out!
This is how to get you.
This is literally how to get you.
Just eliminate me now.
Oh my God.
You couldn't even reach the paintings.
Wait, do we need to render this?
You're too high in 10.
You're increasing.
You're not gonna lag.
And it's also... Just crank it.
You're not... You're not gonna lag, bro.
And just crank it down.
You died in the game.
You died in real life!
Oh my God.
Please.
I think this is psychological torture.
Trying to push us to our limit.
I refuse.
I don't know where you're going.
This is a squid game.
This is actually a squid game.
Hannah.
Did you see the...
This is a squid game IRL.
What's your strat gonna be?
This is a nice strat.
Yeah, it's nice, peace, and quiet.
I feel like this is real squid game.
This is psychological torture.
Well, I've been doing tasks for the past year, so...
I think that should be a good thing.
Yeah, tasks.
They bait us.
They put us in a room.
Hi.
That we got in.
Yeah, daily tasks.
And then they take us back to the lobby.
I want you to win the whole event.
To see who cracks first.
Yeah.
Am I allowed in this corner?
I will try.
I will try, Hannah.
Very good.
You said welcome.
Oh, thank you.
I'll do my best.
Hey, that was mean.
I want you to win.
Can't we share corners?
I can help you.
You can do it.
I believe in you.
Yeah, but we can share corners.
Precious space, guys.
Yeah.
I can share tips with you.
What's the tip?
Don't kill me.
You first.
Hey.
No, I got no tips.
No corner for you.
Oh, my God.
Hey, my other side.
Hey, my friend.
Why?
This is too close to the lobby.
Man, I love how people are screaming because loud equals funny.
Loud equals funny.
I'm going to be so loud to be so funny.
We will.
I'm going to make people laugh.
I'm going to make people laugh by being really loud real quick.
Yeah, do it.
Do it.
Scream.
Scream right now, Gumi.
Do it.
You're going to be so loud to be so funny.
Oh, man.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look, everyone's going to laugh.
What?
Ah!
.
The timing.
I don't want to hear you guys.
.
Silence!
Stop speaking Spanish!
That was a little man.
The grinning!
Heck the heck!
There's no like...
There's no attacks.
Two points for every five minutes they survive.
When being chased, hiders may lock doors behind them at a cost of two points for every locked door.
Additionally, hiders can earn five points for each puzzle they complete around the house.
What's a puzzle?
There are four types of puzzles.
One involves identifying things with eyes that do not belong to them.
Another requires using clues in the walls to unlock an ancient chest.
No!
Third, you must find a key to unlock the chest in the tower.
And the final puzzle type entails locating the witch's hex chest near some stairs.
No!
This is not...
This is a puzzle!
Why did we have these puzzles yesterday?
When a hider is eliminated by a hunter, they will...
This is an actual puzzle!
We had tasks yesterday!
Yesterday's task should have been today's task!
Because they will determine who survives.
To recap, hiders earn points by surviving and completing puzzles.
Hunters earn points by finding and eliminating hiders.
Goodbye.
After each round, players at risk of elimination will be displayed.
In the final round, the 30 contestants with the lowest score will be eliminated.
I'm going to be right here.
This is where I'm going to...
Oh my god.
That's so dumb!
This is a puzzle!
These are puzzles!
These are tasks!
Now the actual puzzles!
No!
I cannot chat!
Help me!
No!
Ah!
Chat!
Chat can't even backseat me on puzzles!
I have to think for my own!
What's the point of being a streamer if we have to do our own thinking?
Wait, what the heck?
Welcome back.
Wait, everybody can talk?
I am.
Silence!
No.
Bro, I was just talking about that.
I like you so much.
I almost remember the bears to die off the map.
Painting?
But then you're giving people free points.
If everyone does that, the round is going to end in like 25 seconds.
Oh jeez.
Well, keep from the chat.
Wait, what's this crap?
I was just feeling like it's fair.
Some of them seem pretty easy.
I think it's better to die early.
That seems hard.
That seems...
Oh!
Like late around?
I could go with the round that's not that bad.
Yo, the timer is longer than the first round, man.
So we're all just going to try to survive as we go?
Yeah, exactly.
So like if you're like up to the first round that means like...
Guys.
This is bad.
I have to think for myself guys.
Guys, this is bad.
Being a hunter the first round is probably the best on Twitter.
I'm supposed to be a puppet for my chat.
Yeah.
And regurgitate everything they tell me.
This is bad.
Oh yeah.
No it is.
I spent 4 years being a streamer to not think for myself.
Oh Mike, you don't want to be...
You want to get turned into a beast or what?
Not everyone seems to be a hunter.
To not do problem solving for myself.
I think...
I don't know if it's better to just die off the map and the first round.
Now, I have to use my brain.
Oh, that's a waste of time.
Guys.
It's not like riding a bicycle where I can just use my brain again.
Guys, it's not like that.
Guys, I'm really stupid.
I don't know if you guys know this.
I'm really, really stupid.
It's not like that, guys.
At this rate, 50% of my brain cells have been on vacation.
And they are not coming back.
They're still using their vacation aids.
Yeah, code for a chest.
Finding a key for a chest.
And then just finding something.
Yeah, and then find a hex chest behind stairs?
Yeah, find a hex chest on stairs.
Okay, but like for the code one, how do you think the code one works?
There will be codes randomly everywhere.
I wonder if the task will disappear after somebody finishes it.
There's no way, right?
If you just follow the horde again.
I don't know.
Alright.
We're going to win, you son of a bitch.
I'm not going to lie, I was just trying to tell him.
You can just hide from the ground.
Wait, how come they can?
Is it like, puta, a bad word?
Me or nay?
How do I know that word?
Wait, why can they swear in Spanish?
Really?
But like, we can't swear in English.
Yeah, but I think that's Spanish.
Wait a minute.
Yeah, it is active.
Yeah, well, I mean like...
I don't know.
I thought the green one that highlights...
Rocks?
I don't think so.
I was listening to the freaking cinematic!
You dumb people!
Sorry, I need to take my meds for like five seconds.
Well, now you can't turn into the props.
That prop won't seem to work for us, too.
Why?
Why is it?
Because if like, you're running past another prop, you're going to think it's fine.
You get free hits that way.
Actually, yeah, no, but you get them slowly and seriously.
They can't even run.
They have moon up out, actually.
I don't know.
Wait, what?
Say that again?
You can...
The prop one?
Imagine you're running past another prop.
You're going to be like, oh, that's chill.
But if it's a...
It could be a hunter.
So like...
You know what I mean?
If you see a prop running, you think there's a hunter behind them.
No, but like...
There's a hint that the hunter can be a prop.
No, I know.
But why as a prop?
Would you see a prop running?
Like, would you not think the hunter's behind them?
They're just looking for things.
No, they're just looking for things.
They could be looking to pass.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, do you know which one's for dice?
Do we think there's only one set of dice for the team?
Or do we think like there's only one set of dice?
There's three.
And you need to do all three.
Yeah.
Do all three of what?
Okay.
You have to do all three of the tasks?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
This is perfect.
Yeah, best bet is just to like figure out how to do them and then hopefully not die.
I also think it would be nice to be the hunter the first round just so you can see things.
I agree.
That's true.
Whoever starts as hunter gets huge advantage.
I just think it's crazy that like being a hunter all you need is five kills and then you get more points than any prop could get.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Yeah, being hunter seems like an advantage.
It's literally like right beside the chest, I love it.
Oh, so it's that simple?
Yeah.
I hope so.
I feel like I should survive.
Well, good luck guys.
Let's see who comes out on the other side.
I feel like I should survive instead of doing tasks if you have to complete all three tasks to get five points.
It's not worth it.
Okay.
Maybe a skull.
Oh, I can't change into a prop.
I can't change into a prop for 12 seconds.
I don't know.
I want to be a...
Wait, can I get on top of here?
All right.
Okay.
That's dumb.
Like the timer is still starting.
How do I lock in?
This is scary.
Rotation locked.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, I'm scared.
I don't know how to lock in.
Oh, rotation lock.
There you go.
Whoa.
Guys.
I want to know...
Is there like each point?
Each point has some kind of a lock.
Each point you get per
puzzle, or is it like you get points for completing all puzzles?
Can you guys let me know that?
Per puzzle, or is it all puzzles?
Okay, yay for per puzzle you get points, nay for you get points for all puzzles.
Oh, per puzzle?
Oh, so it does benefit doing puzzles.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Okay, we just gotta find stuff then.
Told you, some of these are so confusing.
We're supposed to get two points per two minutes.
We live.
I don't know.
Oh god.
I don't know where the puzzles are.
It's scary.
Do I even get any points?
Am I even getting anything?
It's a lot of monsters.
I have to move soon.
Please bypass me soon.
Oh, he's lagging.
No!
Did he?
He was lagging too!
Would I survive longer for two minutes?
Wait, let me check the points again.
Okay, survive for five minutes.
No!
I didn't survive for five minutes!
It was five minutes, not two!
I read it wrong!
It was five minutes, guys!
It wasn't two!
Goodbye.
I thought it said two minutes.
Bro!
Okay, it's like five paragraphs.
Not even paragraphs.
I swear, the rules are like a thousand words.
It's so hard to retain some of the information.
Bro, how did he know?
I locked it.
I locked my rotation.
Bro, okay, the worst part was he was lagging, so I got so confused.
I was like, is he walking past me?
I was like, is that man walking past me or is he trying to kill me?
He's so... he's lagging!
Like, why is he lagging as the monster?
Sad.
Okay, so per puzzle, you can get five.
You didn't get points.
They made it seem like you have to complete all tasks.
So I got confused with that rule.
Yay!
Let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in.
Uh...
Oh, that's why!
Wait, that's actually bullshit!
It reveals a prop!
So that... I didn't know that!
We had no intel as to what they are!
Oh my god!
That's why I was like wondering, I was like, how did they find out?
Like, I was so confused.
Like, how did they find out?
I was... I was like a monster.
Wait, how do we...
Uh...
Bro, what the heck?
Here, fat...
Press F to reveal.
Okay.
Okay, I know like there's a lot of them.
There are no pro...
Yeah!
Oh my god!
So that's how...
That's actually messed up!
If I knew a monster had that ability, I would not just sit there.
I would 100% not just sit there!
That's actually so messed up!
Oh my god, that's so smart.
Jesus.
Wait, I don't remember the skull being there.
Actually, I don't remember in general.
I don't remember what the props were.
It's been so long already.
I already forgot.
Oh my god.
Are they actually still there?
Okay, they're not there then.
They're not there.
There's only one prop remaining?
Bro, what?
Oh my god.
Can't believe it!
This ability, the revealing probability was actually so messed up!
It was so messed up!
No wonder he knew I was just there.
Please wait.
Who has the most points?
Zero points?
Okay, zero points.
Hey, there's me.
Zero points.
That's me.
Wait, we all have zero points.
Oh my god.
I feel like they should've told us what each hunter ability does.
Because like, if I knew that one of the hunters can literally see...
I can literally see what the prop...
I would not have just stood there.
I would've ran away.
Oh my god.
After seeing that, I'm like, what?
I was like, how?
I would've 100% just ran.
Oh my god.
Might as well just be a goddamn...
Being a hunter is just better.
There's like no reason.
I feel.
There's actually no reason to be a prop.
If I was a hunter I can just find people.
Do puzzles or something.
Let's all just be skulls.
Just just kill me now so I can find props.
Just kill me now in game so I can be a hunter.
It's just worth it.
Cards do puzzles.
There's no stuff here.
Where are some of the tasks.
Oh my god.
The thing is.
I feel like that's the I feel like we're all- we all want to be hit by the hunter.
Like, the moment you get hunter, you just- it's like free.
Freelo.
IMO.
All of us is just trying to find, like, the puzzle and stuff.
Wait, no!
I want to be there!
I'm gonna die.
I'd rather- I don't know.
I'd rather just die.
There's no reason.
Oh my god.
I literally don't know where the puzzles are.
Hello?
Puzzles?
We're all just running around with, like, as if headless chickens.
We're all, like, headless chickens right now.
Just running around.
One is an actual chicken!
One of them is even a chicken themselves!
The eyes!
Where are the eyes?
Where are the goddamn eyes?
Bro, I've been moving for, like, 20 years.
You cannot say that.
Your location will be revealed.
I know!
I've been running for 20 years!
I know my location will be revealed!
Yes!
There's three- two out of three course paintings?!
I don't even get that point automatic- Oh, wait.
Oh my god.
The fact that I don't even get that point automatically is the worst part.
No!
Please hit the candle and not me!
Please!
The candle!
No!
I was so close!
Yes!
No!
I got two!
I couldn't find the last painting!
No!
That was so close.
I almost juked them, too!
I almost juked them!
It's GG.
This- this game is hard.
I think it's really hard because, like, the puzzles are, like, so difficult.
And, like, when you're a hunter, you get more out of it as a hunter.
Like, it's so RNG to the fact that you get more points as a- when you- if you get RNG'd as a hunter.
Versus, like, being an object.
So it's already, like, skewed towards RNG for hunters.
Yeah.
Whoever gets, like, good RNG for that- basically...
gets points.
Because there's more props to kill, too.
There's a lot of props, too.
Running around.
And everybody's moving around.
Nobody wants to hide, I feel like.
Like, literally nobody wants to hide.
And then the fact that they have that power to...
see objects.
Like, literally see props is, like, messed up.
I think this should- this game definitely should have been balanced more.
This game definitely feels like it could- it needs a lot of balancing.
I feel.
I think they should remove the monster that could literally see props.
Because, like, we already have to move?
I think, like, because, like, IMO, we already have to move anyway.
So there's no reason for a monster to be able to have, like, the sight to see props.
If we're moving.
If we have one minute to move.
Like, I know, like, the cooldown's really hard.
Like, there's a huge cooldown.
But, like I said, we're already moving.
So it doesn't matter.
Like, it's just better to be the Grinner.
It's just easier.
Oh, there's 13 props remaining.
I know you're all running.
Because you want to do tasks.
Nobody's hiding anymore.
I know that.
I know none of you guys like to hide.
None of you guys like to hide.
Yeah, this has been...
Whoa!
Wait.
This room has...
Wait, they don't change locations?
For rooms?
Wait a minute.
I feel like when you know what the puzzles are...
Wait, that's not fair!
The puzzles aren't locked.
I think.
I think, like, uh...
The puzzles aren't, like, locked to a specific location.
I feel like, right?
Because, like, why would...
Um...
Yeah.
So, like, I could just go there and unlock...
Wait, that's not fair!
We just, like, run...
Yeah!
Okay, guys.
The worst part is that I am directionally challenged.
So I don't really remember where the paintings are.
I guess we just gotta figure out where the paintings are again.
The puzzles...
The fact that the puzzles aren't locked specifically...
So, like, that's one of them.
Like, the intel.
This is the north rooms.
And I guess, like...
X...
Uh...
That?
Yeah.
So that's north room.
So that's one of the puzzles.
Wait, that's not fair!
Wait a minute.
Why don't they rotate that?
They should at least randomize the location.
I feel like they should randomize the locations for this.
Okay.
Where are the other paintings, though?
I feel like people will know where the paintings are better than me.
Because I found two.
But I don't know where the others are.
Where the other paintings are.
Oh my god.
Where's the last prop?
I didn't even get to see...
Okay, courtyard.
Courtyard takes us to this chest.
I mean, we have one minute to run to here.
So, like, me completing one task should be okay.
Question mark.
I just need to go up the stairs.
Okay.
Let's go up the stairs.
For that.
God damn it.
I wish I could, like, have you guys backseat me right now.
My brain is really tired.
I'm really tired.
I'm trying to strategize.
Oh.
One left.
Wherever they are.
Unlike the crowds.
One left.
Oh my god.
This guy might have five points.
God dammit, I know in this group of 80 people have photographic memory so they remember where each prop is.
I can feel it.
I can feel the photographic mem- oh shit.
And I'm gonna hit that by 0 points anyway so it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter, I already have 0 points anyway.
There's me.
There's me over there.
Bro, people have 5 points?
Oh, it's the task.
It's the task!
That's what I'm saying!
They know where to go!
That's literally what I'm saying!
Cause none of the area is randomized!
So they literally are just going the same place.
I wonder if the chest stuff is randomized or not.
That's what I'm saying guys!
Bro, people are hunters, man.
Literally a hunter can kill 5 people and they're safe.
You just need to kill 5.
Come on, hunter, hunter!
80 people, hunter RNG, let's go!
Oh my
god, where is the courtyard?
Guys.
I don't remember where this stuff is.
Wait, a lot of people are going this way.
That's it, that's it, that's it!
Follow the stones!
What?
Oh, what?!
Okay, this is dumb.
Oh my god, please.
And then...
Are you goddamn kidding...
Please.
For the love...
Please, just kill me.
I don't care.
Just...
Just let...
I can't.
Just kill me.
Please, just let me have this, guys.
I can't.
I can't!
I literally can't!
Let me have this, guys!
Please!
Just kill me!
I can't!
I can't even M5!
I can't see!
I literally...
I can't...
Their body block is...
I can't even open it!
Bro!
Bro, we're stuck in third person, so I couldn't even...
I couldn't even hit it!
I wanted to go back to first person.
I actually...
I was like...
I can't!
Just put me back in first person!
I can't do third POV!
Oh my god!
I cannot do third POV, man!
I can't!
It's actually terrible!
Third POV is actually a crime...
for a prop.
Oh my god.
I mean, that can't be the only prop left, right?
Nice!
Oh my god!
That five kill!
I told you it's better!
Wait, what?
Wait...
That's so dumb!
Can I have that five points, sir?
Please?
No, no, no, no...
No fair!
No, I had to wait...
It's not fair!
I had a cooldown!
Oh my god, I had a cooldown!
That could have been my points!
I'm sad.
I literally had a cooldown.
I think it's sad.
Oh my god.
Cooldown shouldn't be a thing.
I'm gonna say it.
The cooldown should not be a thing.
Get rid of them!
Down with cooldowns!
Just the killing cooldown though.
I don't care about the ability cooldown.
Down with the killing cooldown!
I'm not gonna do the chest anymore.
That chest actually messed me up.
That messed me up so much.
Made me so sad.
That would've been an easy 10 points too.
I think that made me so sad.
Literally, if all those monsters didn't block me...
and I just needed to wait 5 more seconds...
10 points.
Oh my god.
And then the monsters that body blocked me...
so I couldn't even see anything.
What the?
Oh, that's the admin.
I was like, what was that?
At least not 0 points, guys.
At least not 0 points.
That's all that matters.
We made it to not 0 points.
Definitely wish a lot of...
I would definitely wish some of these were in the rules.
I know we already had 1,000 words.
But like, if I had 1,500...
I don't mind if it went to 1,500.
I do not mind.
If I already read 1,000, I could read 500 more.
I could've definitely read 500 more words.
Wait, there's so many of us as well!
Okay.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait.
This is so good.
Oh my god.
No wonder they couldn't kill us right off the bat.
I've realized why they couldn't kill us right off the bat!
Oh, it makes sense now!
Why they couldn't kill us right off the bat!
Oh my god.
Everything makes so much more sense now.
Wait.
Oh, there's a bone right here.
There's a bone right...
Wait, what?
What the heck?
No.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, wait.
Come on.
Let me...
Let me munch you.
Let me munch you!
Yes!
Prop kill down.
Yay!
Okay.
Now to wait another minute.
Now to wait one minute, yeah.
I'll just...
Now to wait a minute.
Now to wait 30 seconds.
Yay!
I'm gonna chase you down, sir.
Until it's over.
Until I nom you up.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Come on!
22 sec- nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Come on!
15 seconds!
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
10 seconds!
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Alright.
Time to nom you too.
Come on.
You guys got this, guys.
You guys got this.
You know what?
I... You know what?
Fuck you.
I had to... I got body blocked too.
I got body blocked too!
You don't get to have this.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Wait.
Who nom'd him?
That was my nom!
8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Yes!
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom!
That was my nom time!
Ahahaha!
It's my turn to nom!
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom!
You don't get that.
Forget that!
After all the pain I had to go through.
You don't get that nom.
Oh hey.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom!
Back here!
Ow!
My nom!
Oh, you have cool down.
You have a cool down.
I steal that like how you stole my cool down.
No, I can't see.
Where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, no, my free nom.
What?
There's no way.
Okay, no, no.
Are you serious?
Okay, I'm actually mad.
There's no way.
Like, I had so many points because I nommed.
They're restarting it?
What?
Okay.
That's actually not fair.
I actually don't like that.
Like, I actually had the best round of my life and they're restarting it.
Oh, my God.
That made me sad.
That actually made me sad.
I feel like they should just commit to it.
There's no, they should just commit to it.
Like, honestly, there's no reason to keep.
Because like everybody... because it's RNG for the hunters.
Literally, whoever gets hunters wins.
So, it's like, I don't feel like they should just... they should rerun it because like the people who got hunters last time, like there's no guarantee they're gonna get hunter again.
So like, you might as well just commit to it because they didn't restart the other games when it wasn't fair.
I know like a lot of people complain about this game because the game was That was actually messed up.
But like, I feel like they should have committed.
Because it took like...
We had like a 40 minute delay to set this game up too.
And then, like we already committed four rounds to it.
Like four rounds has been committed already.
I don't even know if I like made it in too.
Like, I don't know if I made it in.
I just feel like, you know...
We already committed four rounds of this.
We might as well just commit to the full...
Just keep going, you know?
At that point, we should just keep going.
I got the hunter too.
And I nom nom nom nom.
I nom nom nom nom.
I worked so hard.
And I don't get to keep my points.
Oh, I get eliminated anyway.
Like what the...
It doesn't matter.
I already got...
Wait, no?
Wait, I don't.
Wait, I would...
Oh no, I do.
I'm 24.
I got eliminated anyway.
And I still said...
Keep it.
People are now complaining because...
People are like...
Some people kept going.
Kept like...
Some people actually stopped playing because they said they're going to rerun it.
So people are mad.
It's like now they're in a lose-lose situation now.
They're in a lose-lose situation because they said like keep it.
But because if they kept it, a lot of people actually...
Like because like...
Uh...
Wait, are we keeping it?
I'm eliminated.
Oh, apparently the chest...
The chest was broken.
Remember that chest?
Guys, I don't even know.
Are we eliminated or not?
Apparently, you know that chest?
Where I was like, what the heck is this chest?
You know?
I was like, what the heck is that chest?
That chest...
That chest was broken for everybody.
Nobody was able to open that chest.
I'm reading the general.
Nobody...
Nobody was able to read that.
Nobody was able to open that chest.
Oh my God.
People are mad.
People are so mad.
Yeah, there's some crucial info not to be given.
Yeah, people are complaining about the fact that...
Hello?
Oh my... people are so angry right now.
I'll be honest.
I was really annoyed throughout the game.
I just did not give a fuck at some point.
Yeah, I was like...
I was complaining because like I didn't know.
They told us a hundred abilities that one of them can literally see.
The prop.
Like...
And so like what's the point of hiding?
They have the ability to see a prop.
And I didn't know.
Three minute cooldown.
Yeah, but like when you start out, you don't know, you know?
So like I stood still because I was like, oh, okay.
I have like 50 seconds and there was like three hunters around me.
And then like and then they wouldn't just walked up to me and killed me.
So I was so confused.
I was like, what the heck?
And then looked at the hundred abilities.
I was like, oh if I knew that that specific monster can see props.
I wouldn't have stood still.
I would have been like, what the heck?
It feels very...
It's hunter-sided.
It's very, it's overly hunter-sided.
Yeah, no, 100%.
And like the puzzles were all the same area.
Yeah, so hunters knew where to camp.
I saw like five different people camping.
Yeah.
Like I had a key and they were camping the chest.
Like it was just joking.
Yeah.
Yeah, like it was just no point.
Like because it would all just like there.
I feel like at that point someone's like you guys are a crime because you don't want to die.
No, because it was bullshit.
Wait, is that?
Guess who complained about that?
You see that?
Sap.
Wait, but Sap got eliminated.
Yeah, but he's like, he's a millionaire.
So he didn't do a fuck.
Yeah.
But then right after that, I was like, oh shit.
He was like, that was the worst game I've ever played.
Like I don't if they run back any other game.
I think it'd be fine rather than rerunning.
Yeah, I feel like it was just I was annoyed.
I was actually here.
I feel like the rules for the hunter.
The hunter ability should have been given to us.
If they already wrote a thousand ways for rules.
They kind of they kind of did give us the hunters abilities in the video, but not really.
I didn't know what it wasn't told to us.
They did.
They did the red one changes into a problem.
The black one.
The black eyeball ones changes into no, the red one can see props.
No, there's two red ones.
Oh, the red dinosaur one has can reveal props for a bit to itself.
I didn't know.
I didn't register that because people were talking to so I didn't register it quite.
Well, yeah, I was really annoyed when people were.
Yeah, it's just I don't know.
I feel like and then.
The fact that I would say we're going to rerun it and then like people actually stop playing.
Was like didn't like apparently a couple people like stopped a couple of people actually stopped playing and got eliminated because they heard it was going to be rerun.
Holy shit.
Sap is angry.
Don't running a different game is not an option.
Don't eliminate anyone.
Just do more.
Limbs for other games.
That game was shit.
Like I okay, you know what?
That's on our side.
Oh my God, they're not running any other games and they want to rerun that same game.
Dude, right running the same game doesn't change.
And yeah, it would be a hundred sided.
It's just Hunter said if I got Hunter to I got Hunter.
So like I saw you catch up in point.
Yeah, I literally caught up because I got like four kills.
And the thing is I tried to get killed early and there was just fuckers dancing around with props because like why would you kill a prop if you're ahead and like you don't.
If you kill them, it's like less props for you.
Yeah.
So they were like camping other props too.
I saw like three people just running around with props for fun.
Yeah.
It's actually I feel like yeah this that one was actually.
Uh, that one.
It was actually messed up.
I feel like.
And the thing is there's so many there's 80 of us too.
So like the fact that there's like 80 of us.
She's gonna be a lot of complaining.
No, like once the event ended or the round ended and we got eliminated.
I saw the general chat move like 20 messages.
Yeah.
It's just like.
I was lucky.
I was like, oh my God, it's so fast.
Nobody is happy.
Damn.
I'm just hopping on balance.
Oh my God.
Wait, what's the chest broken?
Because like people were complaining that the chest was broken.
Yeah, I was.
My chest was laughing at me because I was like, why can't I open the chest?
If you're like laughing at me, I didn't realize the chest was broken.
I just gave up.
The chest was broken.
You can't click the middle part.
I just I just gave up.
Yeah, I was so confused.
I thought I was being stupid.
I thought I was like, why can't I click the middle part?
I'm so confused.
Then my chat was laughing at me.
I thought it was me, but it's not me.
It wasn't me.
Did someone just said just give one thousand to everyone?
Bro.
Okay.
I agree.
I agree you.
1K for everyone.
1K for getting to top 80.
We don't minecrafters don't need 70K.
That shit was so annoying.
Oh, I want like I I think I went fucking nonverbal because I was just so annoyed that I was getting camped or like this.
And now we're having.
I kind of just want it out.
Like is in the fact that it's like 80, 80 people.
80.
Like eight people gets that.
That'd be Hunter.
But there's not enough Hunter spots for everybody.
I'm turning off emote only for now.
Yeah, me too.
Are turning out emo only.
How do you turn off emo only?
I don't know.
My mods still away.
Oh my God.
Am I monitoring your channel?
So I'm I know I am nevermind.
You are you should be.
I don't know.
My let me check.
I'll do.
Oh, no, no, no.
My moderator.
So wait moderator.
Can you?
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
Mine.
All right guys.
Now you can go.
It was awful.
I know it was awful.
You guys can yell now.
It was so fucking bad.
Like I understand the inherent like.
The way they want to do it.
I thought they would at least split lobbies or something.
Yeah, if they split lobbies, that would make sense.
No, and it took like like it took like 40 minutes of prep time.
It took like nearly 40 minutes of prep time just for it to not be.
There was a cool down.
A one minute for the hunters.
Yeah, there was 100s get like a one minute cooldown.
But like if you start as Hunter, I literally got like 20 points from with the cooldowns.
Yeah, cuz like once you start as Hunter, everyone's literally running around trying to do that task.
Also, they did so easy.
I get killed like right off the bat.
And I couldn't tell if you can redo the same task.
If I knew that I would have stayed at the same task.
Wait, you can.
Yeah, it seems like the task.
Reset each round.
Yeah.
If they're not going to randomize the location make there be like a barrier so the hunters can't camp it.
Yeah, I think so.
Like if they make a barrier around a task, at least it like lets a prop get some points when they're camping that shit.
Cuz like on the very first round, I got the key for the chest.
Yeah, it was just a Hunter standing at it right away.
Like I couldn't do nothing.
And then I got chased by another Hunter because they saw I had the key.
Yeah.
And then it's just the fact that like the puzzles didn't rotate and people were just doing the same task over and over again.
And they just had like a pathway to like a path.
If the puzzles like if the puzzles themselves randomized, it would have been more fair because people don't have like a set pathway.
And the fact that they decided that at the very last game that it's not working and then they say it said it in the middle of the game for everybody.
It's what was messed up.
They should have just like said in the first round.
If they didn't.
If they did not say like we should reset then like people would have been fine.
But the fact that they said we should reset and...
Umm Then like then like...
Then they would have been...
Everybody would have been more agreeable with the elimination.
Yeah, a couple of the tasks were definitely broken.
Yeah.
I didn't even realize certain...
I didn't know it.
No, certain items have certain abilities.
Oh my god, woah.
Yeah, apparently some people didn't get Hunter and they're mad.
Because like, they couldn't make it.
Just rerun the pr- I don't want to rerun the dog game, man!
The dog game!
The admins literally said they can't rerun any of the past games.
I don't understand why they couldn't rerun any of the past ones though.
I don't know.
Doki, let's make our own Twitch Rivals.
Yeah, you know they actually offered for me to- Why did you say yes?
What?
Did you say yes?
Is it bad?
No, I'm asking, did you say yes?
Well, we're still- I don't know any other details.
They just asked me if I wanted to do a Twitch Rival.
If you wanted to?
I thought it would be cool.
I'm asking, did you say yes?
Did you say yes?
If you say yes, code a good one at least.
Make sure it's a good one.
Yeah...
Oh yeah, because like, your reputation gets hit for having a bad one.
And it's not even your fault, I feel like.
Not necessarily.
Well, they will say like, oh, remember that HenaXXRose Twitch Rivals that happened?
That one was shit.
Like, it will be tied to your name.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's why.
That's why, that's why.
That's why it's like, risky.
Dude, run a...
Well, I think just Mr. Toast.
Multiple Apex Legends Twitch Rivals.
Oh my god.
There's no winning.
There's actually no winning.
I'm just talking.
Honestly, like, elimination or not, I kind of don't give a fuck at this point.
I think like...
I like how people are like, I got propped four times and made it.
And then they're like, well, to be fair, they are full on Minecraft players, so they know how to...
They have like, set routes and stuff.
I'm too stupid for set routes, man.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't remember where the things are.
Yeah, people are just mad because some people...
Uh...
Some people got eliminated because of the announcement.
Yeah, some people literally are just...
Bam, clicking shit just for...
To test things out because they heard there was a rerun.
Yeah.
So, a lot of people lost a lot of points because of that.
The problem is that with 10 minutes hitting the prop, you gain 4 points while being a hunter.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's so true.
You gain more from being a hunter because like, as a prop, you only gain 4 points for surviving 10 minutes.
When a hunter can get...
You get 2 points.
You get 2 points for 5.
No, for 5 minutes.
Yeah.
And I didn't even get my 2 points from surviving 10 minutes.
I didn't either.
I survived 4 minutes at most.
Because there's just too many hunters.
By the time 4 minutes hit, there's just too many hunters.
And like...
Yo, whoever that is in the fucking general chat is sucking mad dick.
What do you mean you got eliminated and thought the event was fun?
Like the last game or the whole entire event?
I obviously thought that last game was fun.
You're pissing me off.
Pootlicker!
Dickrider!
That last game was not fun.
Don't lie.
That last game was so frustrating.
The Twitch Rivals guy is typing.
Oh shit.
So funny.
There's no way.
I'm about to launch Pok Bro.
if I fucking give a fuck.
What the hell?
Guys, the Twitch Rivals person is...
It's typing now.
The thing is, if they say like eliminate all the people...
They're gonna have 30 really angry... Well, not 29.
No, 28 because I don't care anymore.
28 really angry streamers.
And I think like... I think Sapsnap is in it.
I think... I think Sap is like one of those 28 really angry players that got eliminated.
Because of the lack of clarity in the game mechanics of Pop-on, we've determined that the game did not work fairly.
We invite all players for today who participate in this game to join us tomorrow.
Tomorrow we will run three events starting with Doll Game and the 30 people who should have been eliminated will be eliminated then.
What?
So you're making us fucking get eliminated tomorrow?
I don't get it.
Like what are you saying?
What?
Run three games starting with the Doll Game and the 30 people who should have been eliminated will be eliminated then.
I guess like we're gonna play Doll Game and then we're gonna see who are the 30 people.
That are gonna...
Okay.
I don't know.
What?
Doll Game!
That was so...
That was...
Oh my god.
I hate it.
I think I hate that game the most.
That game was so anxiety and anxiousness.
I think we should go sky.
We should go sky?
I think we go sky, Dokie.
What do you mean sky?
What does that mean?
I can't say it.
But...
Type it.
Alright, I'm gonna type it.
I think we should...
Oh my god.
This game pisses me off.
Yes.
Oh my god.
People are not happy.
Even though we're re-running because we have to come back tomorrow.
So people are not happy.
But there's one person that's extremely happy.
Yeah, I saw that shit.
I saw.
Do you know what I mean?
Let's go.
There is one person.
And it's the one person everyone knows.
Very happy right now.
Very happy.
If they didn't, they would have been eliminated.
And they...
I bet you Twitch staff did not want to piss him off.
Wait, they're kind of spitting.
Wait, hold on.
Pause.
The person typing in chat is kind of spitting.
Wait, why?
What did they say?
They think that the people who made it today should have to play.
And I kind of agree with that.
Yeah, I agree with that, honestly.
But the thing is they have to eliminate 30.
Or they cut the eliminations to, like, 15.
Well, then that one makes sense for the later games.
Because I think they, like, coded it specifically.
Where, um...
Where they're forced...
Sorry, I'm fucking playing Pocket Rogue right now.
Where they're forced to, um, have a set amount of people per day.
Yeah, oh, that's true.
Like, per lobby?
That's true.
Yeah.
What did AntVenom posted?
Someone told me to look at what AntVenom tweeted.
Didn't tweet at all.
Wait, they didn't tweet or say anything.
What do you mean?
Or did they say something in my chat?
Dude, I don't think AntVenom himself would go out of his way to go into your chat.
Yeah, I know.
That's why someone's like, look at what AntVenom...
What did they... I don't know what they said.
I was like, who's AntVenom?
Like, who... I don't even know who that is.
Oh, Megalol.
I was just like, who?
Oh my god, you see, like, people pulling up clips?
I do, I do see it.
Join our voice channel?
Oh my god.
No.
He's being taken.
Oh my god.
Wait, why are they taking this person?
Did this person complain a lot?
I think this person... this person wrote an entire...
Oh, that's the one that wrote, like, three paragraphs of why, like, it's justified to not rerun?
Yeah, yeah.
Like, the one that was like, was the game not fair?
Yes!
Oh, I remember that!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh my god, they're kidnapping them.
They're kidnapping them to talk in voice.
It's Jover.
It's so Jover.
Oh my god, people don't even want to play anymore.
People were like, like, this is messed up, I don't even want to play anymore.
I think they should just give us the money.
Honestly, yeah, just give us...
Dude, just spread it.
Yeah.
At this point.
I think that's the only thing that can make everybody happy, to spread the money.
Because, like...
I mean, if it's like...
We're winning nonetheless.
Yeah, like, just split from the 70k.
Because even so...
Like, they still get like...
Like, 30,000.
That's still a lot of money.
Yeah.
That's like the most...
That's like more than like, any other Twitch Rivals.
Or not even that, just give like 500 each.
That got eliminated.
No, the thing is, first place gets 70k chat.
That's the thing.
First place gets 70k.
So if they take like...
If they just give like 500 to like, all the remaining players that got eliminated.
Then like, at best, not even like...
They can still keep 50k.
Yeah.
Because each like...
The first place can at least keep 50k.
And that's still a lot of money.
50k is still a lot.
There's...
Oh my god, there's another thing.
There's more?
Dude...
I don't even want to look at that.
Wait.
Where's the more?
No, they're just typing.
Oh, no, no.
They're just saying, tomorrow run three events starting with a doll game.
I guess like...
I guess they meant like...
30 people would just be eliminated in general with a doll game.
God, a doll game was so stressful.
I feel like they definitely get a doll game.
I feel like it shouldn't be...
It should be like if you get a safe doll, you should be just safe automatically.
Sorry.
Do you see that?
I'm putting in the cake.
It puts all emojis right away.
That's so tone down.
That's so...
That's right.
That's like, read the room.
For context, basically...
Basically, in announcements, they add all of us and said, Don't forget that Twitch Rivals will be rating and gifting 25 subs to a lucky random channel at the end of the day.
Just make sure to be streaming.
Yeah, and then people...
People are mad right now because it's so...
It's so... oh my god.
And then people are reacting to it and putting like skull emoji and kek.
W.
Dude, the first thing I saw was a skull emoji right away after they posted it.
Yeah, yeah.
The skull emoji.
And someone reacted with the question mark.
Okay, whatever happens, not gonna lie, this was content.
No, it was good content.
Yeah, this is so... like...
It's so fun to see drama when you're not involved in it.
You know?
You get to watch at the sideline as everything's getting cooked right now.
I like how someone was like, please tell me where the last egg is.
Can you guys tell us where the last two eggs are?
Yeah, guys, do you know where the last two eggs are?
Well, if we weren't eliminated, we would tell you.
Wait, what?
Wait, that's messed up.
Do you see that?
What?
Where?
The dolls are ping-based.
So people get to spawn randomly in the same position during the whole...
So if you're closer, you can immediately get targeted.
So, like, if you have worse ping, you basically spawn late.
I got spawned in the same spot each time.
Yeah, I know that, but apparently, like...
Uh...
If you have bad ping, you're closer to the doll.
That's actually messed up.
Wait, what?
That's so messed up.
I did not know that.
Yeah.
I literally pinged them.
Wait, what did... wait, what?
Wrong team chat.
I posted a fucking screen... screenshot of my Pokrogue.
Whoa, you're lagging!
Whoa!
You're lagging!
Wait, 5UP made it in!
Oh, you know what?
Great.
Great for 5UP.
5UP made it in, but he's arguing...
He's representing the people that got eliminated.
Because he was mad that the chest was broken.
It's so funny!
Like, he made it, but, like, he's...
He's just... he's really mad at the chest being broken.
That he's fighting for us.
It's about the principles.
He's a real one.
Representing...
True, to be fair, to be fair, he would've had more points.
He could've... he could've had so much more points if that shit wasn't broken.
That's funny.
That's so funny.
Hey, someone's gotta represent us.
Yeah!
We're not even arguing, we're just watching.
I... I bet you they just didn't wanna make that person mad.
It's true!
Like...
Because he was really mad.
Because if you could've seen the... how mad he was.
Um...
Mr. Krabs!
I'm a Krabs!
Take the 30 eliminated people, have them compete in a separate game.
Okay, well...
Five?
People can't code that shit, man.
Yeah, they can't code that in time.
Use your noggin, man.
I guess they could do that for the dolls.
Someone said I got... wait, is Sylvie trolling?
There's no way you can get 47 points as a hunter!
Oh, over all the rounds.
Oh, she's also one of the hosts.
She's also a host.
Oh.
Wait, as a hunter?
Yeah.
Wait, how the heck did she get 47?
She probably was a hunter multiple rounds.
Wait, she got a hunter multiple rounds?
Probably.
Wait, I thought you could only get it once.
Wait, that's not fair.
No.
You can get...
Girl, that's what people were talking about!
Wait, I didn't realize!
I thought you'd be like, oh, you can get it once and you won't get it again.
But that's actually rigged!
If you can get double hunter!
Wait a minute!
Okay, now I'm mad.
Now I'm mad.
Now I'm gonna start piping.
Now I'm gonna be mad, too.
I went in and be like, well, at least you can get hunter only once if you do get it.
Girl, I got hunters, too!
You get multiple hunters?
Yeah, there's some people who got hunter multiple times.
What is this RNG?
Someone's like, Doki is typing now.
Did you see me tap up?
Hold on.
Wait, give me a second.
I think I should also finish.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm pumped.
This is fun.
I think we should not rerun the game, but I think you should give us our money.
Wait, what?
Honestly?
Just re-divide the prizes and give 500 to the people that got eliminated.
Lemel.
I added Lemel there so people won't take it too seriously, but I'm sort of serious.
I'm not joking.
Hold on.
Don't worry.
I'll support you.
Wait.
She's cooking.
What are you...
I'm probably satisfied.
Got $500 for three days of this?
I'll take that.
I'm going to have to start from day one.
Oh my God!
Look!
Look at what's happening!
What?
Look!
People are mad about the copyright stuff.
To be fair, they like told people that, oh my god, he's calling...
Oh my god, look at this, he's calling and people are reacting.
Oh my god, he's calling people up for the music stuff.
If you guys go see them discord right now.
Mycrafters are fighting.
They're actually fighting.
They're fighting.
Somebody called...
Shakira, Shakira.
Somebody called out...
Somebody called out another Minecrafter for playing music and they responded, cry.
Oh my god.
Damn.
That's actually crazy.
Holy shit, I'm enjoying this now.
What?
I'm down.
I'm down to keep going if I get to see stuff like this.
Fight, fight, fight.
Minecraft fight.
Take it to bed warriors.
They should just take it to the bed warriors to settle.
I think you guys should 1v1.
I think you guys should just take it.
Take it to the bed warriors.
I think you guys should take it to bed.
Who said that?
Some repressed rage there.
Oh my god.
Just give us $500 each.
I'm satisfied.
$500.
Okay, guys.
I think Doki was right.
I think they should give us money.
That's all.
Tongue out emoji.
Bro.
I like how both of us, we don't care anymore.
Like just, we don't even want to come to day 4.
Just give us some money.
I think $500 per person is good.
$500 per person who got eliminated.
We already invested 3 days of this.
Yeah, suck my balls.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
If you guys could only see...
If you guys could only see the skirt fight.
It's actually so good.
I'd be mining.
I say revive everyone from the whole event.
Double the prize pool.
Sorry.
Instead of 70k, the first place player can get 140k.
Let's all donate and double the prize pool.
Oh, my God.
The ad was like, please feel free to log off.
We're continuing to discuss this and working.
Oh, they're still working on a solution.
Girl, is there no solution?
What's going on?
Bro, just end the tournament.
Just end the event.
Check us out already.
Yeah.
Amazon, we know you have a lot of money.
Just increase the prize pool and give us each all of us 3 money.
Amazon, please.
To be fair, Twitch is losing money every year.
If you guys didn't know that, chat.
Yeah, it's been in the negatives for like years now.
They have not been a profit, by the way.
I think like Twitch, like for Amazon, Twitch is like a, like what is it called?
A tax write-off type deal.
Like they know it doesn't profit, but like they're only doing it because it's a nice deal.
It's a nice tax write-off or something.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know what she said.
Yeah, it's like a vanity project.
A loss leader?
What does loss leader mean?
Guys, let's learn economics while people are fighting.
Dude, Tubbo just typed, can I get revived?
Yes, I think we should revive him.
Now that he said something, I agree.
Yeah, I agree.
I like unfairly took his spot.
Someone's like, is there a call going on?
Oh, they want in.
They want in on this.
Guys, I'm glad all of you guys like drama because I saw...
I don't know if it's the same for you, Gumi, but I actually had more people watching now just to know what the fuck is going on.
Just to know what the drama is like right now.
When people are watching the game over screen to know what's going on in the Minecraft wars.
I think I stopped them from talking.
I think...
No!
I don't want to get in a call.
Wait, but we get in a call and mute ourselves.
We can listen to the fight.
I know.
Oh my God.
I think it'd be like Worldstar.
It's going to be like Worldstar.
I think people...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what is he saying in Spanish?
Deep L?
Deep L-ing is?
Deep L-ing?
We're going...
See you tomorrow.
Don't see me tomorrow.
Geez.
Oh my God.
Yeah, it's just a see you tomorrow.
I like how like everybody that was arguing mostly...
Shut the fuck up.
What?
They all shut the fuck up now.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I meant like it was all in English.
Oh my God.
They're beefing.
Look.
Wait, what?
Your takes were not good.
Can I join a voice chat?
Oh my God.
They're going to fight.
They're going to go to voice chat, guys.
Oh my God.
I'm not going to be able to do anything.
Goddamn.
Use your words.
Use your...
Talk to me in person.
No.
Don't use your fucking...
Don't type to me.
You people are warriors.
See if you can say it.
Look me in the eye and say it to my face.
Turn webcam on.
Turn the webcam off and look me in the eye and talk to me like that.
Can we just stop?
I don't feel so good.
Bro, are they going to a different point?
Bro, are they going to a different Minecraft server to talk?
Wait, that's so funny.
Do you see that?
They're not even going to use this server.
Do you know what that stands for?
What?
Oh man, it's like Ultimate Hardcore or something.
Oh my god.
It stands for Hardcore Minecrafters.
It's like an exclusive Minecraft server.
An exclusive Minecraft server voice chat.
Guys, they're not even going to argue in this server.
They're taking it to the Ultimate Hardcore Minecraft server.
With all the Ultimate Hardcore players to duke it out.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
They're going to the... to the like...
This rank Minecraft server.
The fight is not for us peasants.
Oh my god.
They're not even going to let us watch?
They're not?
I know!
What are they tired of?
Tell Aunt Frost to give us an invite right now.
Tell Aunt Frost.
We want to listen in.
It's not fair.
The content we're missing.
I want to know the tea.
Let me in.
I can't believe it.
The offscreen Goku vs Frieza.
Oh my god.
He sent me an invite.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Guys.
We're in the Ultimate Hardcore server.
Wait.
I don't have a roll.
Give me a roll.
Oh my god.
Bro.
I see all the Minecraft players, guys.
Oh my god.
They gave us a roll just to like...
Just to look at the weight here.
We have no roll.
We have no roll so we can't see.
He's the owner of the server.
He's literally the owner of the server.
Give me a fucking roll.
Give us a roll.
Give us a roll right now.
We want to listen.
We want to listen to this fight.
Guys.
We're so cool.
We're so cool that we're in the Ultimate Hardcore Minecraft server.
I'm in.
Wait.
What about me?
I'm not in yet.
I'm not in.
No.
They gave me a roll too.
It's because you're offline.
Okay.
The rare online.
The rare online moment.
I'm here.
Can you give Noki the roll too?
She has a lot to say about this.
I just want you to know I haven't been online for three months.
Or not three months.
For like...
Okay.
I'm gonna... If anything...
Yeah?
But we can't talk to each other.
Yeah.
It's okay.
We can type.
Okay.
I'll type to you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now I'll like read it out loud what you say to my chat.
I'll join.
I'll join and then I'll...
Wait.
I'm not in yet.
I don't have a roll yet.
I told him to give me a roll.
Oh.
Wait.
What about my roll?
Bitch.
I told him to give him a roll.
You just have to wait.
I just have to wait?
We're missing information right now.
We're missing information.
Okay.
You type me the info.
I'll read it out the chat.
Okay.
I'll wait like one minute.
If he doesn't give me a roll, I'm gonna yell at you.
Okay.
I'll call you back then.
Alright.
Okay.
Gumi is gonna give us the insider knowledge.
I still don't have a roll yet.
I still... I still don't have...
We're roll...
Sad.
They're talking about the spawn spots.
They're actually beefing.
I need to know.
Oh my god.
They're actually beefing.
I'm missing a good beefing content.
I can't believe it.
Minecraft streamers are wild.
Bro, apparently they're actually arguing.
Oh my god.
They're talking about spawn spots.
What the heck does that mean?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay guys.
We're gonna...
We don't have the roll yet.
So I'm gonna steal Gumi's content right now.
Guys.
I'm gonna steal Gumi's content.
What the heck is this nerd talk?
Oh my god.
What the heck?
Oh
my god.
Guys.
I got the roll.
No more stealing content.
Okay.
I'm going in.
There's 17 people in this car!
Yo, sorry to interrupt,
but you guys should probably read what someone said.
Don't read it out loud.
You should read it.
That would, like, yeah.
Wait, what?
Hashtag VC.
No, I don't want the world to look at that.
Wait, do I?
Yeah, I figured.
That's what I was thinking as well.
Yeah, I figured as much.
Oh my god.
I just feel like eliminating 30 people off a mad RNG game is a bit crazy.
Isn't that the same thing in the Rock, Paper, Scissors game we played?
No, they can't hear me.
I muted myself on Discord.
I muted myself on Discord, guys.
You can stack a group with your friends.
I think a lot of people walk in the same circles with their friends.
But it's RNG.
I had an alliance of maybe five, six people.
If you queue into your friends, you can 100% trust them.
Versus maybe other people who don't queue into their friends at all.
How is that fair?
I'm not saying it's fair.
Here's the best thing I can say about that.
You're allowed to hear it because other people are showing it.
Other people are showing the nerd fight right now.
They just lied to me on the last round.
We're meant to hear this.
Everyone else is streaming the scum.
That's the game.
I was never a hunter and I still survived.
Bro, is this what Minecraft players talk about?
Is this what they argue about?
The argument there is that it's random.
What I'm saying there is...
Bro, if this was an FPS game right now, I'm going to say it.
If this was an FPS game and there's disagreements, this is going to be...
It would be so much less civil.
Again, another six seconds.
FPS gamers will start saying the most fun stuff.
Fucked up shit.
I don't have to play the game anymore.
It's a different way to play the entire round.
I get a free pass.
Other people don't.
This is actually like a nerd fight right now.
It's different because that's the mechanic of the game.
The mechanic of the game is that you can lie to each other and do that to try and get points.
Whereas with this, there was no mechanic of the game.
If you got hunter round one, you did not have to play the rest of the rounds.
You could have just killed everyone the first round.
I feel like we shouldn't be arguing about...
I got hunter round one.
This is so civilized.
This is an actual debate club right now.
No, I've seen Apex and a lot of people argue.
Nerd fight.
I'm arguing that there were ugly things happening that...
This is an actual argument.
Okay, but the question is...
I think we all agree that we see this shit, right?
Because it's like, bro, I was lowkey thinking that.
You could look at past games and say that.
Where are we drawing the line on what games get rerun?
I've seen fucked up shit when Apex and Overwatch gamers start arguing.
When FPS gamers start arguing, it's actually so messed up.
They get real personal unga bunga.
I feel like I'm in a debate club.
Here's my thing is that this game, there was a lot more factors that were completely RNG.
If you spawned on the east wing, you spawned next to all three paintings.
And so you could just run to all three paintings immediately.
And get 10 points, 15 points, however many points it was.
Just for the paintings.
I'm gonna up the volume so you guys can hear the argument better.
That's five points that you can get if someone has spawned on the west side.
By the time they run to the east side, the hunters are coming out of the door killing them.
So there is no balance in the idea of...
There's more randomness, but we're saying that that's just not a good argument to rerun.
I'm not saying we should rerun.
Let me make that clear.
I guess I should clarify my stance.
I'm not even saying that it should be rerun.
I'm not saying that's the solution.
I'm saying that game should have never been played, right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's the only take that is actually real, I think.
That game was completely unbalanced and it shouldn't have been played.
On the first round, a hunter got 25 points.
And that's just an example of one hunter on the first round.
Right.
In a single round.
That's guaranteed.
100%.
That's only five kills.
One thing I'm saying about that is sure the hunting was OP.
But let's be honest.
When we were all sitting there and looking at the points, we all knew that the hunting side was OP.
Right.
Everyone knew the hunting was going to be OP.
Bro, this is great.
I'm glad I made it to day three.
We knew it.
I'm so happy I made it to day three.
The biggest argument though is yes, we know the hunter is OP.
There's not much you can do about that.
But if the hunter is so OP and the task isn't working.
Yeah.
Then the survivors are playing at such a huge deficit at that point.
What's going on?
That's a goddamn nerd fight.
That's what?
You can't run the game with the survivors already at a disadvantage.
Okay.
I'll show you guys.
Actually, I want to show you guys how many people.
There's a lot.
There's a lot of people in this god.
Because if you spawn at the middle chest, the turning one, for me personally, which I spawn twice, fiddled with it for a solid like minute, does not work for me.
So you can't have that as an argument.
And so if I spawn there and then I just lose the advantage because now I'm at like, what, 20 seconds to find the other tasks and then the hunters just beeline it.
Bro, is this what being in a Minecraft community is like?
You can't have that.
People fight like this?
And so I'm just fucked now.
You don't need to talk about anything else.
You're not allowed to.
You're in Minecraft.
All the fiddle of like the time and everything doesn't matter.
The only thing that actually matters is if the game is good or bad.
You're not allowed to.
That's the only buggy.
Is this every day for them?
That's the only good thing.
It doesn't matter how unbalanced anything is.
It doesn't matter how left or right anything happens.
If things work for some players and don't work for other players and they're doing the same inputs and the same everything, that's, that's what I can give up.
That's just the only thing that makes sense.
Nothing else about the balancing matters at all.
Everyone's going into the same game.
If it just genuinely doesn't work, then that's the only thing that makes sense.
Can I just call to the call?
Because he has good takes.
Who?
Yes, Kyle.
He's adding another person to argue?!
Like the problem was...
The problem with the tomorrow is like one thing that's going to happen is, um...
Bro, did you hear that?
Bro, can we add the other guy?
He has some good points.
You know how at the end of the last game, right?
Or the dull, dull, whatever stupid name it was.
Another fighter has joined the lobby.
You know how when we got it down to just one color, it did the same thing where it just kind of spawned somewhere?
If we had to eliminate six people that last round and there's only one color and it spawned Bro, I'm the only non-Minecraft person in this call.
You know what I mean?
This is like a whole new world for us, guys.
The solution's fixed.
It would have been so random if you spawned in front of it, like randomly.
That's a strategy.
Here comes a new challenger.
No, if you don't know where you're spawning and you just randomly spawn in front of it.
I'm literally like the fly on the wall right now.
No, what I'm saying, what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is, you know how when it got to the end of the game and there was like only one color left, right?
Can someone give a roll?
It just kind of just put it down somewhere and you didn't really get to choose.
Like, it just kind of ended up spawning in front of you because it was only one color left.
So imagine like the last round of tomorrow when you just randomly spawned in front of You need to get rid of six people and it just spawns right in front of you.
Like, that's just unlucky.
My argument, my only argument for that is there is the safe zones, which I'm hoping they would put more in.
And then that's a strategy.
Run to the safe zone.
Oh my God.
Why are they strategizing now?
You can't use that as an argument at all.
The only thing that I can get by at all, there's two things that the admins did wrong.
And it's just, this is an objective fact.
There's two things that they did wrong.
It's an objective fact?
That would cause the game to have to be replayed.
Okay.
The objective fact?
As if there was genuine bugs affecting people playing, that stuff didn't work.
And they were doing the same things with other people.
Like, let me show you the participants.
I'm just checking stuff.
Okay.
There were things that maybe some people could do on low ping, but other people couldn't do on high ping and they didn't test it.
That is valid.
The only other thing that's valid is they canceled it in the middle of the fourth game and some people trolled in their heads knowing that it was going to be canceled because that's what they said.
And now they're going to walk it back.
Those are the only two things.
Every RNG argument, we're not going to get anywhere.
There's no point in even talking about it.
Every single game you will ever play, ever.
In any game.
We're not going to get anywhere.
In Minecraft, it's going to be RNG.
Half of the games in this event were made to have RNG in them because they wanted it to be fair to the lower placing players.
That's why there's RNG factors.
The whole entire point of this event was to maybe see like some random like VTuber versus Feinberg in the final.
That's me!
That was the whole entire point.
If you run back hunt and run 10 times, I think our staff gets the final point.
That's me on the random VTuber!
Oh my god!
If you run this game 10 times, I don't think you see the same person in the final two once.
I just don't think it's going to happen.
So that's the point.
It's designed like that.
So there's the RNG argument literally has no like stake, no impact on anything because it's the point of the event.
You're talking about me!
It's the point of any game.
I think that argument changes my mind because I was against you on this.
I think that the RNG, like the balance of the game was for a $100,000 event.
That's my argument.
That was despicable.
Yeah.
To put $70,000 on the line and then make you play that game.
Exactly.
It's for sure not fair to people.
I don't think anyone disagrees with that take.
All these games we've been playing, like I go into it just being like, I could just randomly, like that curse one, I could randomly just spawn with it and everyone just runs away from me.
Like what was I supposed to do at that point?
Right.
Yeah.
There's a lot of these games.
Now they're doing the doll game, which to me was...
Exactly.
100%.
That's me!
I think the best solution out of all of this, like it sucks to say, calculate the points of the people who got fucked over and then just move the people on, move the fucking top 40 scores.
Because at the end of the day, like I think running it back, I mean, you guys saw the thing in VC, like running it back isn't really the best idea.
Yeah.
I'm a lower class compared to the minecrafters.
No matter what people are going to be fucked over, right?
So I think the best thing you can do, like the best thing you can do in this situation is just calculate the points because obviously there are people that got fucked over like through and like all those people.
I'm in the thick of the Minecraft drama.
Like there was bugs, right?
But it's not like the, the way they make it sound is like, it's only one person experienced a bug or one different person experienced something or like five like a set of people I had the checkbook and you all laughed at me because you thought I fucked up.
We were all given the same thing.
We were all given the same.
That is not true.
We were all given the same idea.
You all laughed at me.
So the best thing that they can do is just count the scores, get a bunch of people and count the scores.
I don't, I don't agree.
Cause you thought it was possible.
I don't agree because there's multiple people, like I said, if I, if the only argument that you guys are going to listen to, it's still the biggest argument.
There's a fundamental flaw with one of the tasks.
People couldn't get points, which they need a survivor.
And therefore they're probably getting eliminated because they didn't get hunter.
That is fundamentally just.
There's nothing to it other than that.
Do we have a disadvantage that you literally couldn't do and then you lose.
And I don't think that's fair for a tournament setting.
I agree.
We never had the same chance of rolling hunter and everybody has the same disadvantage.
No, it's not about that.
It's not about the hunter, it's about the thing not working.
It's not the same disadvantage.
That's an awful argument to say you had a disadvantage of thing breaking.
Some people's it worked.
All right.
If it works for some people, it should work for everybody.
So that's a terrible argument.
Right.
I also think that the RNG argument is a bit flawed too.
Yeah.
The RNG argument is way different because if you RNG and happen to be a hunter, then now congratulations, you can easily rack up 20 to 30 points this round by being a hunter the entire game while other people would never have the opportunity to do that no matter when they die or when they became a hunter or how many points they tried to get while they were as a prop.
You can never get that number of points.
Do I have any Minecraft viewers?
How long do these arguments last?
Yeah, but that's the point of the event.
Because they already sort of figured it out.
No, but it's not supposed to be...
I do understand that argument.
Okay.
I do.
I do understand.
Like, I understand the RNG is bad and the game is bad.
As someone in here that like...
How long do these arguments go?
If it was full skill-based, I should be in the top 20, right?
I'm like, sure, whatever.
Right?
Like, I'm not looking forward to playing these games, right?
Like, I'm not looking forward to getting random targeted by a doll, random spawn with a Guys, some of them make like actual spreadsheets because they're speedrunners.
Random not choosing a hunter.
Like, I didn't give them the throw for once.
Minecraft speedrunners are on a whole nother level.
It's a mix of RNG and skill.
People qualify being prop all four times.
And I guarantee you there were people who didn't.
There were people that were hunter starting that didn't qualify starting as hunter and then propping three times.
I'm willing to guarantee you could add, like, you'd have to look at every VOD, right?
But there's just, there's just no, like, I would honestly, I would, I would put money onto the fact that whoever got hunter first round probably made it through.
That's so true.
I agree.
The 90% minimum got through.
Yeah.
Oh, didn't you start us on their first round of zero points?
I started off as hunter.
First round.
I got 20.
And the second round I got zero.
And then second, third round I think I got, like, five.
And then the last one I think I got, like, five.
Yeah, but you started as hunter and got 20 points.
You started as hunter and got 20.
You got more points than I got the entire game as hunter in a single round.
The reason I got more points is because, like, I was just stealing people's kills.
Yeah.
It's still getting a kill.
Right.
Exactly.
You were still getting kills though.
Right.
Exactly.
And then there was a cool down for you to get kills.
No matter what.
There was two rounds I could have got, like, 15 points as the hunter, but I only got five because you're on a cool down for a minute.
So, like, I don't know.
I don't want to start the hunter conversation.
Again, like...
They should do bedwars right now.
This is a bedwars settlement.
...wholeheartedly with the whole, like, things not working.
The hunter topic is just fundamentally flawed because at the end of the day, we all knew before the event... the game started that hunting would be everyone's best chance of surviving.
And...
Yep.
We just got unlucky.
And, like...
What's the general...
I was annoyed...
I got unlucky...
What's the general consensus for, like, what should happen?
Man, they're actually constructed.
Well, the biggest problem...
Let's just keep it kind of straight, more or less.
Ninety percent of the people that are...
We're in the 40% are probably gonna be like yeah Let's just eliminate them and then most of the 90% of the 30 people are gonna say the same thing No, let's just do something again.
Like no matter what like people are gonna be mad
It depends on what the next games are cuz I don't think playing the doll game again is also a good solution No, I agree.
That's my biggest gripe with the solution is like I don't like I'm like the audience right now I have no idea what's going on in the Minecraft area Very common
I would hate to be eliminated from the game if it came down to me not being able to do the chest twice Even though I was there and had time to do it
I mean, that's something they could do, but have people report it individually and show the clip.
If you got scuffed by that lag or by that glitch, have you send them a clip and then do the calculation based off of that.
But there's still the fourth round, where people trolled because they thought it was getting restarted.
Okay, but there was only two props left.
Oh man, you guys should have seen the Discord.
The Discord peep, like the chat peep, was actually crazy.
It was insane.
They're so civilized in the voice call, but the Discord fight was insane.
When they're typing, it was so bad.
People were actually fighting in the chat.
Someone literally responded.
Someone called somebody out, and then the person responded with cry.
I was like, what?
That's stupid.
Tell us now.
Let us know.
We'll look at your bots and give you back your normal points.
And if you would have made it, you would have made it.
I think the only, if you're trying to make it the most balanced quote-on-quote, which I still think is not balanced because the game is flawed.
But the most balanced would be if you genuinely got bugged, either by not getting points for survival or the chest not working.
What's going on?
We're watching a Minecraft fight right now.
I don't know which ones.
We're listening into a Minecraft fight.
Sure, submitting a clip and having them do all the calculations.
I guess is, in theory, the most fair way to do it.
Sure.
Now, it's still not fair.
I'm getting Christian.
At the end of the day, this is a Minecraft new challenger is here.
I feel like we still had a good four minutes left.
But there was like two people alive.
If you found the person, like, PG.
Play the fourth round again, and that's it.
If you had to play the fourth round again, you just couldn't count that round.
But you can't do that because now everyone's going to know the rest and just look at bots.
Just stop it before that round.
Oh, sorry, before they said it.
Before they announced it.
Just those two people that were left as props.
They're still going.
Apparently this lasts for a while.
I don't know.
Is this what it feels like to be a reaction channel?
But I'm reacting to stuff live?
Bro, I'm patient zero.
I'm here, like, I'm in the drama.
No, all 30 people have to get eliminated.
It's not 30 people going into the doll game.
30 people have to get eliminated.
Everyone goes into the doll game.
If they change their mind and, like, send the 30 eliminations into doll game and let in...
Oh, shit, did people leak the Discord chats?
Wait, what got leaked?
Eventually the games tomorrow won't work for those people.
Oh, my God.
Are the Latin American streamers mad?
Are they farting?
Wait, was it a Latin American streamer that called out...
Oh, my God.
Oh!
You can't give up a spamming chat and someone's going to stop being the most annoying.
You can't add points to that because that happens to people who survived and then it's just like...
We saw that!
That was like one of the shoes top!
I think it should be added if people stand clicked and lost all their points at the end and also the hiding bonus.
Because that's literally...
The chat has a free combo code.
I lost five points to that and I still...
A lot of people that are arguing qualified in this.
It's more of just like...
Yeah, exactly.
Everyone that's putting on one side...
I don't want to guess, but I'm going to guess.
Sam, did you not qualify?
What?
Oh, no, no.
I got eliminated.
I'm just saying, you're on the opposite side.
Obviously, you're going to walk.
No, no.
That's why 90% are going to say both sides.
The thing is, you're saying that.
I actually don't think the game should be replayed at all.
I don't think that should happen.
I think that makes no sense.
I don't even know if they should try and do all this shenanigary where they try and fix the eliminations or whatever.
I don't think that's correct.
You were just saying things with 5-0.
That's why I was like, oh, maybe...
What I'm saying is that that game was fundamentally flawed from the beginning, right?
There was never going to be a good outcome by playing that game.
And I think that that was realized by most people round one.
In my VOD, you can go watch my VOD.
In round one, I said, okay, so you cannot win as a prop.
I literally said that.
You cannot win as the prop.
You're not going to win as the prop.
I didn't realize how one-sided it was going to be.
That's actually crazy.
And that was exactly what I said.
There's multiple dramas.
Guys!
I'm so happy I made it to day three.
It should not be played.
When there's money on the line or something, you shouldn't do that.
This is what I saw.
It should have been stopped round one.
Exactly.
That's exactly what I think.
That's the biggest thing.
Have a day three surviving.
You've come to a point, though, where this is very important.
Where you're saying, you know, the entire event...
Wait!
People turning!
Tomorrow could be even worse.
Oh my God, that's crazy!
At this point, putting us all into the doll game tomorrow, 70 people, is like putting us in a blender.
Oh my God!
Right.
I don't think that's fair.
I don't think that they should do something where...
10% of the people that survived.
This time will probably get eliminated.
And they'll be...
I'm going to be honest.
If I get eliminated...
If they do the doll game tomorrow and I get eliminated because of it, I'll be pissed.
Right.
Don't worry.
I'd be mad.
Would you not be?
We can think it's not fair.
But it's like, it's literally the point of how they designed the event and how they designed the game.
Bro, people have to turn on one camera to argue!
I can't let random VTubers have a chance.
These games have had significantly more randomness than other potential rivals that we've...
like, that have existed right in the past.
Like the 2021 Minecraft Rivals.
Right.
Rivals is always scuffed in RNG.
But this...
The point of this event is...
I can't believe it.
I think you guys are getting mixed up with what...
There's two...
There's multiple different types of RNG.
All the other events that we've done so far is a different type of RNG to this.
Yes.
I agree 100%.
It's completely unbalanced RNG.
It's RNG that everyone is going through.
But this is not...
It was still unbalanced.
It's in the doll game.
But if you're in the doll game...
The doll game is a little bit unbalanced as well.
There's a group of 30 people running into a hallway and then there's a doll in front of it.
You can still...
You still...
How does the AI choose...
I disagree with that.
The only part in the doll game that was unfair is the spawn.
If you are right next to the yellow blonde doll that...
You're sending me some of the tweets.
That's the whole thing.
Everything else was like...
Now you have decisions on if you want to be in the middle of the group or if you want to be behind.
How do you react?
The fact that Sap actually attacked the Latin American...
But now you've got like...
The fact that Sap actually antagonized the Spanish speaking streamers?
That's so crazy.
Can we revive Red Velvet because he couldn't do anything against that blonde dude?
Oh my god.
You know what I mean?
That's the whole thing.
We could go back into games and be like...
Bro, did they not learn what happened in Rust?
Any game could have had a little problem.
Like Red.
I feel bad for Red.
That was a crazy drama.
But we're not talking about reviving Red now.
Oh my god.
It just gave me like Rust memories.
Like even with the RNG of today...
Like I'll be fully honest.
I got Hunter round one and that obviously gave me a buff.
But in the three rounds after that...
What was that?
So like there was a similar situation and why like Rust is like now divided in between...
Now like different.
Because in the past, Rust would invite like separate communities together.
But it got really bad for one of them to the point where they don't do that anymore.
For Rust.
That's why they don't do Rust Twitch Rivals anymore.
And in those three rounds as a prop, I got instant elims and I got enough kills to just go through just off of that.
And I think that was awesome.
Yeah, the Rust Twitch Rivals.
This is basically like the Rust Twitch Rivals.
That's just the name of the game.
Like it was stupid.
It was like...
I will agree.
Like the Hunter thing was just dumb.
But we all knew it going into it.
Are we still talking about the Hunter thing?
Like 90 % of the people here probably had an idea that maybe we should just die right away and just respawn.
I got 25 of my 30 points from just being...
I never personally killed myself.
I never got to be a Hunter.
And I still survived.
I only killed one person.
Yeah, I never intentionally killed myself either.
And I made it fine.
I did have one round as Hunter.
But like...
It was possible.
My first round I got almost no points.
And so it was fine.
But I didn't...
Yeah, sure.
You've got to be a Hunter.
But like there's people that survive.
Like again, like would like random VTuber number 13 survive being a Hunter like a Hydra three, four times?
No.
Look, look, I'm not like...
What I'm going to say, I don't want everyone to think that like I'm coke and saying that I need to change it.
I don't carry the weight.
Because the thing is, I was propped four times, right?
It was impossible for me to have ever won the game.
I literally could never win the game.
The first two rounds, I could not get any points because I couldn't run around.
Oh my God.
How could you?
I'm not just random VTuber number 13.
I'm random VTuber number one.
I'm a pro.
That's a lot of intense.
But by way of a heads up.
I mean, if I would have gotten the  at one point, I never would have been able That is saying, bro, I like was a for the first semicolons of it.
If I would have done it, I can...
yeah.
I can popping food off you.
Can I walk an extra mile to the top of yours?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You need some whipps to...
Bye -bye.
Uh, I have one more thing.
Uh -huh.
Then how could you ever say that if somebody said, oh, today's game was complete bull, and they're mad, how could you ever disagree with them?
You're basically agreeing by saying that you would be mad if you got eliminated tomorrow.
Right, right, right.
The counter to that kind of is like I was saying earlier, besides the glitchy things, we all knew that it was dumb.
We all knew going into the game, the point, how it was going to run, what points we would get where.
I agree with 5up with the point of that people that didn't get points because of being buggy is fundamentally the problem.
That's the number one problem in this whole entire thing, and them calling it early.
The reason that if I was to have lost, and whatever, get a second chance, I'd feel like I was lucky, because I knew going into the game that I had to just rage that I'd get RNG Hunter, and if I didn't, I'd probably get eliminated.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, that's basically what I'm saying.
Yeah, it's true.
We can all agree, Hunter was bullshit.
Like, why are we still arguing about this?
Like, why are we still arguing about the Hunter?
We all know it's bullshit.
If you did it three times, then you would have been eliminated if it just didn't work for you.
You would have been at risk.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying too.
What's a word?
If then we were to give people points for that too, right?
I could literally say the same thing of just being like, oh, I spent 40 seconds doing it, so I could have survived if I had been hiding instead, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
What's the guys' consensus right now?
Nothing.
Is this something that we're...
Here's my question.
Why is it consensus after REA 534?
Is anything we say having an effect on this or not?
Probably not.
Yeah, we're just yelling at each other for no reason.
Obviously it's not going to happen.
There's no fruitful end of the conversation.
Yeah.
Unless there's an actual end.
Well, we'll probably look through the Discord chat and see what people think.
I just want to know...
I want you guys to answer some questions for me just because I'm curious.
Not that this would affect literally anything.
Okay.
What is the problem with the doll game?
The problem with the doll game is if you spawn next to the...
Okay, so there was set spawn points when the doll actually spawns itself.
All right?
I know.
So if you spawned next to that spawn point of specifically the yellow doll or other dolls, it's going to fundamentally seek you and the other people can just run just on spawn points.
There's nothing you can do.
And so if you change the spawn points to where that's where you voted and that's where you were going to start instead of your set spawn, that helps a lot.
The only flaw then becomes the final round.
Where does the doll spawn when the entire circle is the same color?
Yep.
Because then if you are randomly...
Let's say like the last round is that like blonde doll and it just like you are like happened to be right where it spawns.
It's just going to immediately speed 20 at you and kill you.
I think a blonde doll is problematic as how it works.
But the problem is too if we do the doll game again and we don't have that blonde one, we will be waiting for three hours for everyone to die because it already took long enough with the other ones.
And we survive sometimes with the other ones.
Like if we don't like have that random RNG effect to it, skill will come into a factor and we'll all just survive.
What if they give you longer grace period?
Bro are we like...
Are the minecrafters...
Guys we are getting intel for the next event.
Yeah that would help.
As long as they like...
I mean the problem is it seems like the things don't move.
Like they move randomly until they get close enough and then they start hunting.
It's like if we all...
If they like wait two seconds, we are all going to be like sitting in corners for like a minute waiting for them to randomly like walk into our hallway and then like attack us.
You know what I mean?
I mean there were multiple rounds during the doll game.
That I'm like running at the front of the group.
I ran into the doll and because of the way the doll AY works like you can just turn around immediately and like pass your hitbox past someone else's and it will never target you.
Yep.
If you...
It was never even hunted.
It all takes like five seconds to hit you.
If you...
I mean that's just...
Bro they're so mad that random VTuber number 13 made it here.
I don't understand why I got brought up like two to three times.
Like...
Bro...
I'm sorry for eliminating...
I'm sorry for...
...eliminating...
...your fellow Minecraft players.
It might be.
Why not just put people in that like whole potato game and let like...
Well actually I guess...
That's actually crazy.
...I guess if people can't be added to tomorrow...
Put all 70 of us in Hot Potato and we'll just let it play out.
I mean that would basically be the same thing as the one game right?
I mean...
You guys know there's random VTuber streams on YouTube.
You can control your fate more with Hot Potato.
What are the other ones?
I don't know.
What about the...
At least with Hot Potato I can find Feinberg and try and give him the potato all game.
I mean...
Oh my god they're laughing now!
They're reconnecting!
The people agree that if they reviewed the VODs and added in the points for...
We might agree but they might not.
For survival slash...
For people who spam...
Well I mean obviously they're going to do that right?
Like obviously they're going to do that.
Like that has to be done.
Like if there were survival points...
I don't know.
If people tried to do things...
They won't.
They won't do anything about this game if they're just gonna have it all survive tomorrow.
That has to be done.
Oh no.
I mean obviously I think we already know that's not happening.
Like that's not going to occur.
That's what they said.
I don't expect...
That's what they said right now.
Right now that's what I'm planning for.
That we're playing that game tomorrow.
That's what I'm planning for.
And obviously like I think the best thing is like if that happens we all just like accept it.
Go GG.
Like GG go next.
And...
Oh my god they're finally accepting it.
I don't know.
Like not have a rift be between us as players.
That was literally what I said at the end of my stream.
I was like at the end of the day like it's a game.
We were playing a game.
Yeah.
Like nobody should be mad at anybody.
Nobody should be like hating on other people.
Like it's a game.
Like we're playing a game.
Yes it was definitely dumb but I mean it's just a game.
Like...
Oh my god the recuts.
Oh my god guys.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
It changes the dynamic when there's 70k on the line or whatever.
Friendship wins.
And then the game is super RNG or whatever.
It's like definitely changes the vibe and is very tilting.
Like when you feel like you can't do anything.
They're finally agreeing that it's RNG.
I don't know.
What I was trying to say earlier Sam.
Even though like you said you don't care and I'm not saying this now to like say that you do care or anything like that.
Yeah.
It's like the people that do care that will be eliminated today will be mad.
And if we switch it the people that did survive are gonna be mad.
Not at specific people.
Like I'm not mad at anyone here.
But like someone is gonna be mad no matter what happens now.
Guys we went through a character arc guys.
No matter what they choose.
It's like watching a movie.
We're just gonna have to deal with it and if you're pissy just don't play another Rivals I guess.
I don't know.
Yeah I mean.
30 people gone to dull RNG or 30 people gone to that game though.
Right exactly.
That's the question right.
That's what it comes down to is are we are we killing 30 people to a game that was the hunter game or just to dull game right because they have to kill 30 people.
Right I agree.
I think the dull game was completely unbalanced the whole time.
I had a goaded spawn.
I spawned in green and like the dolls are spawning on the opposite half the entire game so I just got to run away at the beginning for free.
I mean.
Oh yeah.
I mean there but there's strategy to that.
Like um if I will agree that I I just like.
I can't believe it.
I was like Sapnap just yelled everyone to go on the other side so they listen to him.
And they the the doll always just spawned on the other side because Sapnap would just scream and then like that skill to where like that's why like me and Feinberg didn't have to worry about anything.
The power of friendship.
The good ending.
The only problem.
What a twist.
We're talking about like unfairness in any game and every single thing whatever blah blah blah blah blah.
Someone like Red would have been unfairly killed because there was just physically nothing they could have done.
I watched Red's POV.
He could have gone on the other door because he ran for a riskier door.
Um.
That's the only argument I have.
Sure.
For that.
There is a thing he could have done.
He watched other people's POV.
Is it the best?
No.
He also didn't find any safe zone just in the area he's running.
That's the only argument but there was something he could have done technically.
And that same thought process is that there could have been other things.
There was not anything people could have done technically for a chest not working.
Just not doing it.
Yeah.
They're gonna have gold mole points from the rest of the game.
I mean what they could have done is.
I guess if you were arguing that.
Probably bot reviewing guys.
I told you Minecraft streamers.
You're a whole nother level.
Especially speedrunners.
Every round it got like a million points.
Here's the thing though.
Is that.
Yeah they're bot reviewing.
How do they have time to bot review?
It's actually not ideal though.
This guy literally bot reviewed in the middle of between games.
Round 1 and round 2 you're actually giving whoever spawned as hunter way more points by like intentionally dying to them.
The hunter 1 round.
They just probably got like a billion points because the spawn time was like one and a Yeah the spawn time should have been consistent.
The only way to fix the game is this.
Everyone should have got a turn to be the hunter.
And everyone should have had turns that they were not the hunter.
Everyone should have got one turn to be the hunter.
That way everybody gets a chance to be hunter.
And also whenever you're not hunter and whenever you die or whatever.
You should just have the same respawn timer across all four rounds.
For those who are FPS streamers this is a whole new level for us.
This is how arguments should be.
Like hunter the next round.
Let alone the people who are the props.
You have a way big advantage.
I've never experienced this before.
Just because you were hunter at the beginning and there's a cooldown timer.
And that's all because there's a cooldown on like killing.
Right?
There's a cooldown on killing.
Which means that there being a cooldown for respawning.
When you spam cooldowns like this into a game then it like leads to situations where like inherently just terrible gameplay emerges.
It's so civil.
The thing is it's civil but like nothing is being agreed upon.
I agree.
They probably should have told us about.
Cause like somebody or one of the organizers came in and was like so what did you guys agree on?
Now I know what happened.
The person hunting me that was standing on top of me was on kill cooldown.
But I didn't know.
He was on kill cooldown.
I'm like trying to hide.
Right?
And like so I have no idea that bro can't kill me right now.
What I should do is run away.
I have no idea of that.
But again.
Again though.
That's part of the game.
Right?
Like that's part of the game is you don't know everything.
Some people turned their webcams on.
That was crazy.
It's very disambiguous I guess.
I like said that as a joke.
About how like turn the webcam on.
Look into his eye.
To debate.
And some people actually did that.
I was like oh my god.
This is serious.
We knew the spawn time when we started the game.
Cause people were saying like oh it's one minute and a half.
Like we knew that stuff sucked.
And it was like the kill codon stuff was stupid.
We should have known that.
But um.
Like everything that was like knowledge that we knew.
Like once you like played around.
Like if you figured out all the stuff were in the same spots every single time.
That's just like that is just knowledge.
The biggest problem with that game is that people weren't getting points because the thing was buggy.
That's inherently the only problem.
If you didn't get hunter.
That just kind of RNG starts to beat you.
Yeah this feels like a court trial.
You can still survive if you like did this or that.
Or this or that.
But inherently if you didn't get hunter.
It is LU at that point.
Like every game in this whole entire event and continue to be will probably have some type of dumb RNG that like if you don't like.
Call me out.
Call me out right now.
Your head is going to explode.
I don't know.
Call me out.
Call out the random beat you're wearing.
Like who even knows.
Like the last game to decide who wins this event could be like oh does your name start with the letter F?
Oh congratulations you win.
For $70,000.
This guy coded it from above you hear that?
This guy is cheating.
Like inherently like the games coming up too could be problematic too.
And then what are we going to do for every single game?
Like oh.
I think the only thing I the only reason that I feel like they need to do something about this game was because everyone knew during round one that like the game was just scuffed.
Like it was just a scuffed game.
Like even.
Right.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what should have happened.
Is the rivals.
People should have said wait a minute.
This doesn't make any sense.
You know what's messed up.
Like look at the disparity and like the points already after a singular round.
The organizer has been listening to this.
We know that like.
One of the organizers has been listening to this and they.
One round two automatic.
Having these people call her events scuffed.
I feel so bad.
She has been.
She has been listening to this.
We're playing in a lot of events that cost a lot of money.
They were in the call.
The thing that people failed to do.
He dipped down.
They did.
They never test the game in a computer.
True.
Yeah.
With competitive players.
The game is never tested in a way where like.
We got 70k on the line.
Yeah.
You just take a hundred people out of fucking.
I agree with that.
The fact that there's 70k on the line.
Yeah.
And the games weren't as well tested as it was.
They figure out everything.
Because like.
I've had to test games out before.
One time.
The fact that like.
They didn't test the game.
They didn't test the games enough.
If.
With the quantity of people.
Hear me out Twitch Rivals.
If you're hearing this.
If Twitch Rivals.
Offered me.
Like.
To like.
Make sure their events weren't dumb.
I would do that.
Than playing this.
You know what I mean?
Like.
Yeah.
But would you do it for free?
They just need to like.
Make sure.
That like.
Their things are fair.
And do something like that.
Offer people 10 bucks.
To just play their game for an hour.
And then give feedback.
Yeah.
That's just something I've learned.
By playing like.
All of Carlin.
Oh.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
Um.
At least.
Twitch Rivals.
Do you hear that?
If they weren't going to do the doll game thing.
Well then.
At that point.
How did more people join back?
They didn't do the doll thing.
That's how people left.
Yeah.
If they didn't do the doll game.
They'd have to give.
The survival points to people.
And then.
Give back the points.
That people randomly.
Killed.
Like.
Killed like.
Their points.
By punching random things.
And then.
Does everyone agree.
That that's better than.
The doll game?
Yeah.
A million percent.
I'm pretty sure.
Every single person would agree.
Yeah.
Well.
I mean.
Obviously.
That game's dumber than the doll game.
But.
It's a good idea.
Have people open a ticket.
If they.
Genuinely experienced a bug.
Or trolled.
At the end of the last round.
After they said it was cancelled.
That's what I think too.
Reach out.
With the points.
And go from there.
That's.
I feel like.
That's like.
The only way.
To do anything about it.
Right?
I think if.
The staff knew.
That like.
Most people agree.
On something.
They.
Can make a better.
Like decision.
Obviously.
Not to like.
Tell them what to do.
But.
Sure.
I feel like.
Everybody.
Everybody prefers that.
Over the doll game.
And probably.
Even some people.
Who got eliminated.
Would agree that like.
Just give us $500.
I don't care anymore.
In order to like.
Calculate those.
Completely bugged points.
Yeah.
Like.
To be clear.
I don't want to come back tomorrow.
From.
Like.
Whatever.
And then.
Like.
I'm one of the people.
That got eliminated.
Right.
Like.
I don't want to come.
Start streaming tomorrow.
And start playing.
Rivals.
Like.
I don't understand.
Because.
The way they word it.
Is like.
Kind of.
Disambiguous.
As well.
In the discord.
About that.
So.
Like.
I don't know.
I agree.
I think.
That the only way.
They can do.
Anything.
That's remotely fair.
Is to.
Take.
All of the streams.
And everyone who says.
That they didn't get points.
They should have got.
And to fix their points.
And then see.
Who the 30 were.
Or whatever.
People can lie.
Regardless of how that.
Oh wait.
No.
There's clips.
Whoever gets eliminated from that.
Then that was how the game.
Should have eliminated you.
Right.
So that's just the only fair way.
It's not fair.
Because like.
People can like.
Just say.
And the points that people like.
Once they said.
That they were throwing.
Like.
Sure.
Yeah.
Like.
Give back the points.
Yeah.
You should get those back.
Well that's like.
I was throwing the last game.
The only reason they should get those points back.
Is because they said.
They were rewriting the game.
Yeah.
Exactly.
If they say.
They're rewriting the game.
Then everything is like.
Up in the air.
At that point.
Basically.
I stopped.
Nomming.
As a hunter.
Because I thought it was over.
And I killed them.
So that should be.
5 points.
My chest.
Was broken.
That's another 5 points.
That like random person.
That's 10 points.
Right there.
10 points.
I stopped.
Nomming.
Guys.
You were all there.
Like.
I will.
No.
Sorry.
You go.
I was gonna say.
Like.
There might be like.
Someone.
That was like.
Like.
The chest was broken.
I got laughed at.
By my chat.
I should get.
15 points.
If they like.
To justify.
My mental.
For those survival points.
And get eliminated.
But like.
That I mean.
That inherently.
They would have lost.
If.
Those people got their.
Designed.
Point.
And then I saw.
My chat.
Laughing at me.
That I couldn't.
Open.
The chest.
At the end of the day.
None of us.
Can get mad at each other.
And.
If.
We decide.
To do.
A doll game.
We.
Shut our mouths.
And just play the doll game.
If they eliminate.
30 people.
If you get eliminated.
Or you survive.
Fine.
Five day event.
Starting tomorrow.
Fine.
Just start it over.
Five more days.
Back to back.
What was the point of this argument?
If we're just gonna settle.
With what was originally.
Agreed upon.
Like no one should get mad.
At each other.
Like us.
Players.
Should get mad.
At each other.
The only person.
To be frustrated at.
Is the people.
Who allowed the game.
To be played.
Like that.
It's the only.
That's exactly.
What I said.
At the end of my stream.
As well.
Nobody should be.
If we did the dog game.
Tomorrow.
And I agree.
It has always been.
An issue.
With rivals.
It always will be.
An issue.
With rivals.
Because.
I don't understand.
Nothing happened.
They just argued.
For the sake of.
Arguing.
It just went.
With the original intent.
Like.
Pieces.
Of RNG.
And like.
Random factors.
That could boost.
Like a random player.
To be better.
What kind of drops.
Is there.
For Minecraft.
Apparently.
For money.
We all want.
To try our best.
Oh.
Another thing.
I just learned.
I don't even know.
If this conversation.
Is still going.
Sorry to interrupt.
Go ahead.
There you go.
The hunters.
This wasn't said.
In the rules.
The hunters.
If you kill a person.
You were at a minute cooldown.
Where you couldn't kill anybody.
Yeah.
We already talked about that.
There was multiple rounds.
I would have got.
Like 15 points.
There was two rounds.
There was a terrible.
There was one round.
Tell us that.
I don't know.
I wouldn't tell us that.
I don't know why.
That wouldn't be like.
They should have said that in the rules.
Well.
And like round one.
Round one.
I already said.
Like I was getting stood on.
By a guy that was on kill cooldown.
And I had no idea.
I had no idea.
There was a.
That chest with the key.
There was just one of them.
Standing in front of there.
And I was like.
I'm going to get these five points.
Just to get these five points.
And if he kills me afterwards.
Oh well.
And he just looked at me.
And I was like.
All right.
My guy.
Like got me up.
Like thanks.
I guess.
All right.
Bye.
And I left.
But now that you mentioned.
Once I realized that.
Like I killed him.
I had cool.
Kill cooldown.
I realized it now.
That like.
That guy probably just.
Literally couldn't kill me.
Yeah.
But that's a.
They should have put that in the rules.
That's really weird.
That they didn't add the cooldown.
Stuff to the rules.
But inherently.
That was a part of the game.
And like.
That's like.
I mean.
Sucks to be you.
If you could have gotten.
A triple combo.
I guess.
Jesus Christ.
Hitboxes were cooked.
Or something.
And then.
Like.
After round three.
I like realized.
I was like.
Oh.
Like.
There's just a cooldown.
I didn't see it.
But there is.
Yeah.
I mean.
I think that the number one mistake.
Is a classic Twitch Rivals move.
And the number one mistake.
Is that at the end of the game.
They said.
That they were going to redo the game.
Which they should have.
Yeah.
The fact that they said.
Before the game ended.
Classic.
Do things.
Rivals move.
And then.
The going into the third.
End of the third round.
I was still.
I never was a hunter.
I was out of the top.
Bottom 30.
And I was like.
Perfect.
I'm surviving.
Cool.
Whatever.
And then.
I did my two challenges.
I was like.
Okay.
I'm at 30 points.
Awesome.
I think I'll be fine.
And then immediately.
When they said.
Oh yeah.
By the way.
We're not.
This doesn't count.
I was immediately like.
Well.
I was probably going to survive.
And now.
I'm not.
Again.
I mean.
If they end up.
Choosing.
To do whatever they want.
Tomorrow.
Like.
That's their choice.
And whatever.
And if I lose.
In the doll game.
Tomorrow.
If they end up doing that.
I mean.
Oh well.
You know.
Like.
GG.
I guess.
No.
For 50 minutes.
Everybody.
Just.
Accepted.
It.
.
Did everyone have.
Have fun today?
Yeah.
I had fun.
I mean.
I was like.
Yeah.
With all my friends.
It's good.
So fun to play.
Even if it didn't really.
Function.
All that.
Well.
I've never been.
More stressed.
In a Minecraft.
Event.
Ever in my life.
Before playing.
This dumb.
Stupid.
Stinky.
Event.
I was happy.
When I.
I thought I survived the main for day four, but...
Bro, did we just go through the five stages of grief for Minecraft players?
Like, for the Minecraft players?
Just going through the stages of grief there?
Bro, what was the point?
What was the point of this?
There's never, like I said earlier, there's never going to be an answer at least that makes everyone happy.
There will be 5, 10, 20 people on either side that will be pissed tomorrow.
I think they hit an acceptance.
Or whenever they make their final decision.
They've hit the acceptance stage.
That's just inherently going to happen.
And that sucks, but...
Acceptance has been reached.
If it works in your favor, if it doesn't...
Automatically, what ends up happening, whenever there's a problem, immediately the people that were going to get eliminated are going to be like, yes, please, do it again.
And then the people that survived are obviously going to be like, no, please don't.
I want to win 70 grand.
Bro, no, I just wanted $500.
You got to think about, like, inherently, like, what the idea of this whole entire event was supposed to be.
And...
Like...
Am I sure for day 4?
Like, that we're trying to do that one code thing?
Like, ended up trying to do it all four rounds?
That's kind of on them.
No offense, that's kind of on them.
Not saying they did.
I just thought it was stupid!
Or you thought it was broken?
Why are you doing it more than once?
I just thought it is!
If those people, if they got five extra points and survived, I'd be like, yeah.
I'd be upset.
But if they had, like, zero points going into the last round, or, like, zero points just in general, you were going to get out even if you did do that.
Four times.
Like, you know what I mean?
Damn.
That's not me.
I don't know how much I laughed at me!
And if, like, people survived five minutes and didn't get points for that too, they should get those points and then calculate, see what they get.
And if people survived because of it, W.
If you don't, you probably wouldn't have survived anyways.
So...
Wow.
I mean, he's not wrong.
I am surprised I made it this far.
I'm surprised I got it here.
I got here.
That just means tomorrow we get to play three games if we play the dog game.
Hey.
Isn't that fun?
No?
Okay.
Guys, is my voice still messed up?
No.
What do you think?
Sorry, I'll meet up again.
You don't have to meet up.
No, please do.
I've been sick for the past three days.
Alright, guys, I think debate's over.
Actually, no, it's been more than six months.
Do you think the debate is over?
I've been in the rain, bro, and then he got sick.
Can we leave now?
Hey, game's game.
Wow.
Bro, what a...
That was... that was crazy.
That's actually crazy.
During the entire time, I ordered soup, I ordered a sandwich.
I caught a genusect on pokeroad.
I was just listening in.
I was actually insane.
Does this happen often in Minecraft?
Girl, I don't fucking know.
Bro, the fact that they debated for more than an hour straight.
But then they had zero... it just went back in a circle.
They agreed to nothing.
They actually... they just accepted.
But it was crazy.
It was crazy.
There was one part that I did tune back in.
And then I heard Viva say some shit.
Like, guys, actually there was something they didn't tell us.
For Hunter's set.
Hunter's set had a one minute cooldown.
And everyone in Unison said we talked about that.
That's so true, yeah.
Yeah, that was so true.
That was so fucking fun.
Oh my god.
That was actually crazy.
I was so surprised.
I was like...
What am I listening to?
Oh my god.
Everyone in Unison, they already told us.
Did you see the... the fight?
The... you know the tweets they linked?
That was linked to us?
Yeah.
I can't believe the Discord got leaked.
They leaked it on stream.
Did you know that?
Yeah, I saw that shit.
Bro, they actually...
We're talking about the...
They called out the Discord fight.
The Discord chat fight.
And people were leaking the chat logs on stream.
Not us.
We were just telling you guys.
We just called out who it was.
But we were just like...
Oh my god, people are fighting.
But some people were actually...
Some streamers that were participating in the Twitch Rivals actually leaked the Discord chat logs on stream.
It was crazy.
Bro, I'm glad we made it to Day 3, Gumi.
We would have missed out.
Yeah.
We would have.
Are you coming back for Day 4?
Yeah, see you tomorrow.
Let's play the doll game again.
When will we...
I'm gonna win.
I just have to beat a doll game.
That was like one of the most stressful ones.
When will we...
It'll be okay.
When will we win?
Alright.
Okay, I'll see you on Day 4, Gumi.
What if we're not playing Valorant?
Wait, what?
What?
I'll see you on Day 4, Gumi.
No, how about Valorant?
Gumi, I just went through!
Gumi!
Huh?
Hello?
Gumi, this stream could have ended two hours ago.
Wait.
Oh.
Hello?
Vtuber number 13?
Hey, that's me.
Hey, man, I'm a Vtuber.
I kept, like, I called out, like, three times.
Like, I...
I feel like they're like, this Vtuber should not have made it this far, but because of RNG, she's here, too.
That was so fucking good, they mentioned you, like, multiple times.
Yeah!
Like, what the fuck did I do?
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I got it because of R&G.
She eliminated Tubbo.
Alright, GG's.
I'm gonna talk to my chat.
Gumi, please.
Please.
I'll play Valorant tomorrow, Gumi.
Okay!
Bye, Toki!
Bye, Gumi!
Bye-bye!
Alright, guys.
That was wild.
That was actually wild.
I did not expect today's Minecraft day to be like this.
Day 4.
We're back with Day 4.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
There's multiple fights going on right now.
And I'm just like this random...
I am the random one.
I'm VTuber number 13 looking in the sidelines.
Being like, what the hell is going on?
What the fuck is...
There's like...
Sap is trending on Twitter because of the leaks.
We listened in to a fucking Minecraft debate for an hour.
Oh my god.
Also, like, yeah.
I only streamed the call because everybody else was streaming the call anyway.
So I was like, alright.
That was weird.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
It was pretty civilized though.
That was pretty civilized though, for a debate... for a debate about a game.
I think my favorite part was when they ended it with like did you guys have fun?
After people were like mad.
Did you guys have fun?
Oh my god.
Anyway, guys, for those who are new here, welcome to my channel.
We're not a drama channel.
We just got roped in.
I'm literally not a Minecraft player.
Like, I got invited to the Minecraft Twitch Rivals, and I was like, that's fun.
And I think I'm one of the few streamers that are not part of the Minecraft community that's made it this far, that's still in it.
Because, like, there's not a lot of us left.
There's definitely not a lot of us left.
So, um, so, uh, and by the way, please check me out on YouTube.
I usually stream on Twitch when it comes to Twitch events, which was this event, so that's why I'm here.
Uh, and I...
That's why I'm here.
Uh, so check me out on YouTube.
You guys wanna know when I stream on Twitch?
It'll be, uh, it'll be like, uh, tomorrow at 12pm, same time.
I will be on...
Uh, I will usually tweet out whenever uh, I usually tweet out whenever the...
whenever I'm streaming on Twitch, so please follow me on Twitter.
I heard that my YouTube's figure is up now.
I don't know if it's up for pre-order now.
So, like, I don't know if Imod has made a command for it, or anything, but yes, I will tweet out the announcement for my YouTube's figure.
Um, it came out during the middle of all of this, so I couldn't.
Oh, it opens for pre-orders on the 11th.
So, it opens for pre-orders on the 11th.
So, yeah, I'll tweet that out later.
Sorry, in the midst of all this drama, like, I couldn't...
It's Minecraft drama.
The thing is, it's Minecraft drama, and my...
The thing about Minecraft drama is that there's drama, um, almost every week.
To the point where, like, people are gonna forget about it so soon.
Like, I swear, even somebody who's not even part of the Minecraft community, I always see Minecraft drama.
So, like, I feel like it just...
There's always stuff happening.
There's always stuff happening, so, like, I'm not surprised.
Um...
So, yeah, that was, like...
That was fun.
That...
Anyway, guys.
Yeah!
I had a great time.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Poster check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
What a rest week, guys.
What a rest week.
The people on YouTube sure are missing out right now.
Did not expect my run for this event to lead this way.
Hey, guys.
See you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!